this is jocko podcast number 268 with
echo charles
and me jaco willink good evening echo
good evening
and also joining us tonight is
leif babbitt a good evening life good
evening good to be here
all right so i can't say it like that
who can though well i don't know you put
your own spin on it right
i mean that's hard when he gets warmed
up it just does it so well though i mean
the bar is high
we were we were backstage at
the first jocko live actually was it was
it wasn't jacqueline was in new york
city
oh yeah and someone someone said
something to you like oh or
are you nervous and you said well a
little bit
and then well okay
i'm trying to craft the conversation
maybe that didn't happen the way you're
looking at me
somebody was talking to you and somehow
you rehearsed your lines no no you
wasn't it was
tai was making the video and you were
like you know i'm over here going over
what i'm gonna say
and no that was me taking a nap or
something
i think it was just in passing tai was
making a video okay you were doing
nothing like you're doing whatever
you're doing and then
i was just saying good evening i decided
to be funny i guess
because that's your job what's funny is
i jammed that
up did you if you listen for which one
for that for 160 in new york yeah
when i say good emails like good evening
like i jammed it up
i think in that weird you have one job
one time
you have one child
is the pressure greater on you right to
get those words right exactly
since they're limited exactly right well
what was crazy about that was like
no you didn't know what i was going to
talk about no and the only person that
knew what i was going to talk about was
me
and i knew i was going to go out there
and talk about seth and it was going to
be like
as hard of a thing as i could possibly
have to go and talk about
and so you're all kind of hey you know
cool this is a crowd
it'll be fun and i'm sitting there
thinking how am i going to get through
this
and then i do get through my part and
then you screw up your part
uh thankfully in a way i screwed up my
part
before you did your part you know
uh i knew something was kind of i don't
wanna say off because it wasn't off but
something was a little bit different
when you rolled up like when you came
onto the stage
wait a second
something's different right now because
i didn't know what was going on at that
time yeah
but which is weird i didn't give you any
heads up at all
no sir you did not what a savage savage
that's all
hey man it's real yeah you did that to
me at the the jocko live
in austin as well like no heads up
whatsoever and you read you know reading
seth's words and
talk about us working together and stuff
he'd written about me that i never even
heard you know
heard before and uh it was i was like
bawling my eyes out in the background
actually you came up to me afterwards if
you go you go how about a heads up
next time and i go sorry bro you go i
was openly weeping
and i was like dang that's rough uh
yeah um well so anyways let's hear your
good evening one more time leave
i mean what do we got good evening there
you go
i mean everyone always everyone always
likes the lathbab and texas batman
thing that you yeah you've got going on
right i agree
i guess you can just gargle rocks or uh
yell and scream over the sound of
gunfire
do you remember when we were in south
africa on the radio
i do have you ever shared that story
with uh
anyone in your life particularly the
person that you're married to
we're on this radio show it's a big
popular radio show in south africa
and you know we're getting interviewed
about leadership and we're talking and
these these females are calling into the
show and they're like
that man's voice is amazing i can't do a
south african's
voice but it was uh it was pretty funny
wait that's
is that public that that interview
it's on youtube right now it might be
yeah i think i saw that
it was pretty funny i remember you guys
being in south africa on the in
in that radio show and it's on youtube
okay well there you go we can look it up
there you go we can tag it wait what do
they say
we'll put that in the show notes i would
say that but i know that there's a
limited chance of you putting anything
in the show notes
what's the show notes uh i don't know
it's on
on the podcast you know you can put
youtube the description
description but also on people do that
on do you know
when people put a a podcast on itunes
for instance
you can put links in there echo
yeah you can put them in the show notes
so people say i'll link it in the show
notes
all right so i'm not making any
remote promises about anything mean in
the show notes
i guess you can use your google fingers
if you want to see leif
getting complimented by
the ladies of south africa or let's say
some of the ladies in south africa
it's on youtube it's it's it's out there
all right so
now that we've gotten through that
let's get into the subject of the night
the subject of the night is the squad
leader makes a difference
the squad leader makes a difference and
with decentralized command which is the
fourth law of combat leadership this is
undisputable it's undisputable that the
squad leader
makes a difference because with
decentralized command everybody leads
you want everybody to be a leader and
lately i have been talking about the
fact that the purest and
highest form of decentralized command is
actually culture
and if you have a strong culture inside
of an organization
then the people in the organization at
any level
can make decisions based on the culture
of the organization
just based on the culture they can
figure out what to do if you have a
strong culture
if it's we take care of the customer
think of how many decisions you can make
if you know hey our culture is to take
care of the customer
you can make all kinds of decisions if
your culture is
we have the highest quality we make the
highest quality product
oh should i cut the corner here no you
shouldn't should i
should i get a little cheaper
material to put in here no you shouldn't
we make the highest
quality product which means that culture
drives decision making
we have the best value we give the best
value oh what does that mean we're going
to try and maintain that low price we
can make decisions you know what we can
shave off a little bit of money
there and we can get a better value for
our clients so you can make all kinds of
decisions with that
and the military has culture too and
units in the military different units in
the military right down to the platoon
level
have a culture that can also drive
decision making
it can drive good decision making
actually
and it can also make it can also drive
bad decision making right if you have
bad culture it can actually drive
bad decision making so
real obvious example bad culture is a
bad culture of
blaming others of not taking ownership
and if you're not taking ownership
you have a culture where nothing ever
gets fixed that's what's happening
so if our culture is to blame everyone
else
we're not we're not going to improve
we're not going to get any better
obviously
again if we have a culture where we're
cutting corners i don't worry about it
that's when accidents happen
if we have a culture where we're looking
out for me
right i'm that's looking out for for
jocko
well then um we're not covered moving
for each other
i'm not there to cover and move for
someone that needs help
if i've got a culture of micromanagement
guess what
no one's going to have any initiative
because the culture is sit around and
wait and get told what to do
so you can see how these cultures drive
bad decision-making
of course culture can also drive a good
decision making
right with with good culture if you've
got good culture
if you've got a culture of ownership if
everyone in your team is
has got the culture where hey we take
ownership we solve problems guess what
that culture is going to drive people to
say hey you know what that's my fault
let me fix it
so we want that culture of ownership we
want
the culture where people don't cut
corners we want the culture where people
look out for their teammates
we want culture where people are
empowered
and they make things happen so it's
it's real obvious how powerful culture
can be
and i think sometimes people think about
culture as
is like non-quantifiable well you know
they have a good culture but what does
that really
what does that produce what does that
give you the reality is if you have good
culture it is
extremely powerful it's the highest form
of decentralized command and
decentralized command
is extremely powerful in its own right
so then the question becomes okay how do
we actually
create culture how do we do that how are
we going to create culture
and the answer is if you think about it
for a little bit the answer is that you
create culture the same way that
culture has always been created how does
culture
get created we have to tell the story
we have to have we have to we have to
share this story we have to explain what
we've been through
what we've done together who we are what
our history is
what we stand for and actually and
actually why we stand for that
and if you can carry on that story if
you can tell that powerful story
you can create a culture
now we can't just make the story up
we can't just we can't we can't just
fabricate or actually no
uh we actually can you actually can just
create
a a a story almost out of thin air
and if you if you use that story you've
used that lie
to replace the story and you tell that
lie for long enough
it becomes the truth right 1984. that's
exactly what that's the whole premise of
1984.
we control he who controls what is it
who controls the past consoles the
president who controls the present
controls the future
no who controls the present controls the
past and who controls the past controls
the future
whatever order you want to put those in
if i can convince you
that this is the story this is the
history this is where we came from
i can manipulate the culture so
so it actually can be done
but that takes like a massive kind of
universal propaganda machine
to make that happen
and i think the the better way to do
that and what we should do and what good
leaders do
is to base the story
that develops into our culture based
that obviously based in the truth
the most powerful way to create a
culture
is to tell that truthful story to hold
up those examples
from the path from the past those those
values that got us to where we are
those heroes that stood for those values
you tell that story
and that becomes the culture
and one of the strongest cultures
that i've ever been around is the
culture of
the united states marine corps
and they do it in a bunch of different
ways
but but what we're going to talk about
today
is a shining example it's a shining
example of how to create culture
because they have a manual they have a
manual
the manual is called the squad leader
makes a difference
think about this black belt move they
make
they make a document that's called the
squad
leader makes a difference
so obviously they want to have
decentralized commands they want their
squad leaders to step up and lead
so they make a whole manual that's
called the squad leader
makes a difference
and it goes further to set the culture
inside the document itself
because in this book the squad leader
makes a difference which is subtitles
subtitled readings on combat at the
squad level
and it's from the marine corps war
fighting lab
which is which is a legit name for
something at quantico
it's put this thing was put together in
1998 by a couple lieutenants
m obaldi no idea how to pronounce your
name i apologize an
a.m otero so these guys put together
this manual
and you're going to see that what it is
actually doing
is telling these stories
and building a culture of decentralized
command
where everyone is a leader and the squad
leaders can
make a difference leif i was thinking
when you were at the naval academy what
examples
how was that culture like when you when
you looked at the marine corps
they did did that culture permeate into
the
young life babin brain and pull you in
that direction a little bit
yeah for sure i mean we had some some
outstanding uh not commissioned officers
sergeant major that ran our pt and he
come running by at four o'clock in the
morning and
yelling for the brigade of midshipmen to
get up you know
and uh it was yeah just there was there
was a lot of that was uh
in fact i remember on parents uh parents
weekend so you go through like the plebe
summer
which is so you just show up in the
naval camp it's kind of boot camp at the
naval academy it's pl
we call it police summer so you show up
and they're running all these midshipmen
to
boot camp you're you're kind of going
through that boot camp style and toward
the end of that your your parents shall
show up for parents weekend and they can
visit for a few days and see you
and then they they take off but he was
uh
he was like talking to the parents he
was like who here's who here is from
maine and
uh and so you know a few people raised
their hand like oh yeah he's for me he's
like i'm from maine too the main part of
paris island
and he just starts laughing and it was
uh just you know
that was certainly instilled in us and
everyone has to go through you know
whether you're going to be a
ship driver in the navy or submarines or
fly airplanes or
or whatever you have to go through uh
you know at least
at least a two or three week program
that's kind of like ocs
down in quantico it's i mean they they
do it at ocs and quantico for the marine
corps so you get a taste of that
regardless
and uh so that whole the whole thing of
every marina rifleman and putting folks
through that was uh
was very appealing to me and i went
there because i wanted to be a seal
uh but uh certainly uh marine ground
was my second choice which i did not get
selected for
dang um
two things isn't it interesting the way
that
just saying that this guy would run by
at four o'clock in the morning
just makes you think good to go
that's number one and when i was going
through officer candidate school which
is also run
by well the marine corps is are the are
the drill instructors
and we would we were going for a run
and every day we'd run through like a
like a officer real officer housing
where the officers that were stationed
in pensacola lived
and you know every day we'd be singing
cadence and then you go through there
and you have to get quiet and they would
just do
like a quiet little cadence just to keep
you in step and then you'd get through
and then you'd start
saying it again and you know it'd be
four or five o'clock in the morning or
whatever
so one time we got this this one drill
instructor wasn't my normal drill
instructor this other drill instructor
took us for a run
and he was he was new and he was all
kinds of fired up
and so we so we get to that area and he
like gets real quiet
and so you know he's saying whatever the
cadence was and then
all of a sudden he he sings as the
cadence he's like
get out of the rack like quiet and we're
all like get out of the rack and he's
like
get out of the wreck and we're like get
out of the rack and he get out of the
rack
and so we're five o'clock in the morning
run by all these
officers housing and by the end we're
just getting out of the rock and just
screaming
and that was a good time i was like so
that's what the marine corps does that's
what the marine corps does
they make a human being say i'm from
maine
the main part of paris island that's
what the marine corps does
and we must salute them for that
so this book is one of those things when
i when i'm on my
when i'm on my track trails
through the world i stumble upon these
things this is one of those things i saw
that title i'm like you've got to be
kidding me
what is this so uh the squad leader
makes a difference reading on combat
at the squad level volume one and by the
way this is volume one
i have not been able to find volume two
three four five or six
so maybe these guys got sent somewhere
from the
marine corps warfighting lab and didn't
ever make another one
but let's get into it
here's the forward in combat
sometimes when i read these things i
think every single thing that i'm about
to read
i just read it and stop this is one of
those things
so in combat the actions of individual
leaders affect the outcome of the entire
battle squad leaders make decisions and
take actions
which if which can affect the
operational and strategic
levels of war well-trained squad leaders
play an important role as combat
decision makers on the battlefield
leaders who show initiative judgment and
courage
will achieve decisive results not only
at the squad level
but in the broader context of battle
without competent squad leaders capable
of carrying out of
a commander's intent even the best plans
are doomed to failure
so you know you hear about
the general and the colonel and the
captain
and even the gunnery sergeant you hear
about the marine corps leadership
and and yes they're outstanding
but when you're a corporal
and you read this you think you know
what i gotta get mine too
think of how awesome that is and and
from a from a
you know from a business perspective
how how how how do you
what story do you tell your employees
what story do you tell the people that
work inside your organization
what story do you tell them do you tell
them that
that that they are decision makers do
you tell them that
their judgment and initiative will drive
results
at the strategic level do you ever tell
you to team that
that's how you set the culture
that you know as you're reading that i'm
thinking about as a student of history
and i love reading history books and
obviously you do you know you've done
some amazing books here
on the podcast but we always talk about
it from the big
you know the big the commander the
general you read
you know julius caesar maneuvered his
his t or alexander the great did this or
uh napoleon did this or patton moved his
army here
and uh he might have been making some
overall decisions but
the army that's moving is is the the
front line leaders out there the squad
leaders that are executing that and
making it happen
and i love the way we do that echelon
front we're
our definition of leadership as
everybody is a leader and you said
something uh
recently that i i hadn't thought about
it that way but
we're okay who is actually a leader if
you interact with humans
in some way and actually need them to go
in a direction and work together or
provide a
resource or support then you actually
are a leader
and i think when you see yourself that
way uh
i mean the most powerful armies in the
world the most powerful teams companies
in the world
are going to see themselves where
everyone sees themselves as a leader
able to solve problems
and make things happen and move the team
forward in the direction they need to go
yeah that's um and that's one of the
best things about this podcast is that i
get to
i get to read books not written by the
general not written by the admiral
but written by a rifle
one of napoleon's rifleman or a machine
gunner and stalingrad like that's
that's where that's who we're hearing
from and what's what's
what's powerful about that is then you
get to see
you get to know you get to learn how
that leadership
is perceived by the troops on the front
line i mean
that that podcast that we did about
stalingrad where you
they were hearing hitler talk
about them being gone
they were still there they were
surrounded they were fighting for their
lives
and they were hearing the broadcast of
hitler saying it was a great sacrifice
and they stood to the last man
they're like we're still here what are
you doing give us help give us support
let us let us break out no
and you realize oh those well those
people on the front lines
they do they they make such a big
difference
and if you set the culture correctly
they will have even more impact
goes on this this public this
publication illustrates how bold
imaginative squad leaders
impact the outcome of a battle or
campaign
the historical examples here represent
some of the cases in which squad leaders
were able to change the course of
history
did i just say a squad leader changed
the course of history
yes i did in each case the squad leader
had to make a quick decision without
direct orders
act independently and accept
responsibility for the results
short lessons are presented at the end
of each story these lessons
should help you realize how important
your decisions are to your marines and
your commander
in combat you must think beyond the
squad level
you must develop opportunities for your
commander to exploit
your every action must support your
commander's intent
you must be competent in the combat
skills required
of a combined arms leader
you are the primary warfighter of the
marine corps
boom freaking legit
i think about how often like how
different that is right from the
culture of centralized command where the
the senior leaders like we or the
frontline troops just don't get it they
don't know what's
they don't understand and then and then
the frontline troops are like the
the guys up in the ivory tower you know
the senior leaders they don't get it
they don't understand what's going on
here
versus it you know where people are just
sitting around waiting to be told what
to do
versus the the team that's actually
empowered to step up and lead and make
things happen
and that team is just unstoppable
unstoppable
here's some quotes that this thing
starts off with the most brilliant plan
depends for its tactical execution on
the squad leaders
poor squad leaders may ruin the best
laid plans
first rate squad leaders often save
badly devised plans
the squad leader is the sole level of
command
that maintains direct contact with the
men
who do the actual fighting
it follows then that the squad leader is
to be trained as a tactical commander
and as an educator of his men that's
interesting because
you know when we talk about span of
control
and on the battlefield you know you can
have
four five six guys and you can pretty
much
control them you can pre you can you can
you can make things happen
you know when you've got four five six
guys maybe seven
it starts getting really wonky at eight
but that's because you can see them
they're right there you can you can
move four feet and you can grab leaf and
say hey move a little further forward
you can actually just make things happen
through
direct supervision so that's that's
that's very important to remember that
these squad leaders are the ones that
actually are have the contact to make
things happen you go up one level
you go from the squad to the platoon
well that platoon commander can't get to
that kid over on the left flank
he can't get to that machine gunner up
on that knoll he's not gonna be able to
get there
he's not gonna be able to make it happen
and that's why as you grow you have to
get better at the laws of combat you
have to get better decentralized command
you have to get better to keep things
simple you have to get better prioritize
next year you have to get better
cover move because you don't have that
direct control anymore
you can't just you know use your force
of will to make things happen go grab a
guy
you need to get over here it doesn't
work anymore
continuing on the idf this guy's israeli
the idf
squad leaders are trained to command
independently in the field
modern armies operate in small dispersed
formations
all levels of command must be trained to
think and act independently
modern weapons which provide small
groups of men greater firepower and
flexibility of movement
call for a high standard of command at
all levels and this is something that
we've been able to walk through and i
apologize that it hasn't been
chronological in nature
but when the machine gun came
we had to start using decentralized
command because if we're all bunched up
together
we're all going to die together so
that's when world war one
towards the end of world war one we
started getting decentralized command
and started having the squad like
you're not going to be with me anymore
hey leif when we go on this mission
i'm not going to be able to give you any
guidance at all
as the company commander because you're
going to be
400 meters away we have no radios
and you just are going to have to make
things happen you have to know what
we're trying to make happen you got to
go do it on your own
so this idea that you know when you saw
the
the red coats right line up and we're
going to march together that's the old
way of war
i mean the the romans the phalanx like
all the old formations of war it was
like we're all together
we can just maintain good control over
this big group
easier because we're all co-located
and modern warfare brought us to hey
i'm not right there i we launched on
this mission
and i might not see you again until the
mission's complete
so the people that are out there leading
have to know
what they're doing why they're doing it
they have to understand the commander's
intent
and they have to take initiative to get
to that goal
and he fall he concludes this with the
squad leader
therefore the squad leader is therefore
to be trained technically
as an officer not as a corporal
and that's from yigal alan who is a
field commander in the israeli
defense force and he actually was a
scout with the brits in world war ii
fought in syria fought in lebanon
founding member of the israeli
strike force so some experience
uh first they kicked this whole thing
off and this was this was actually a big
shocker to me
they they kicked us off by talking about
corporal alvin york
united states army right so
i expected this to be all marines but
the marine corps is awesome
and they said hey these are awesome
examples of where a squad leader made a
difference
and we're going to use them
france 1918
the muse argonne offensive
was the last important battle of the
first world war on the night of 25
september 1918
over one million american soldiers moved
up to relieve the french forces on the
front lines
the american advance that ensued swept
easily through the first two lines of
german trenches
and then progress slowed facing stiff
resistance
the reserve division was called up
corporal alvin york served as an
infantry man
in the 82nd division
york's company started across a valley
at six in the morning as they began to
move the company came
under heavy fire from behind a hill
enemy machine guns
mowed down the first wave of advancing
americans
no one knew where the deadly fire was
coming from so
york's platoon sergeant decided to take
the platoon on a mission to find it
the platoon found a gap in the enemy
lines and circled to the rear
where they thought the machine guns
might be the group of americans
stumbled across two german
litter-bearers whom
they followed back to the headquarters
of the machine gun battalion
the americans walked right into the
german machine gun command post
opened fire and the germans immediately
surrendered
upon hearing the fire behind them the
germans
that were dug in near the command post
swung their weapons around and began
firing at the americans
caught in the open in a hail of
automatic fire the americans instantly
took casualties
corporal york took aim at the nearest
machine gun
about 25 yards away and killed the man
behind the gun
he continued to fire each german who
popped his head out of a foxhole
after watching his troops being
massacred by this lone
sharpshooter the german major in command
yelled
to york if you'll stop shooting
i'll make them surrender
work on your marksmanship people work on
your marksmanship
within minutes the remaining american
troops had captured
90 german prisoners but they were behind
enemy lines
corporal york took charge and quickly
organized his platoon
he decided to move back towards friendly
positions straight through the german
lines
york ordered the german prisoners to
carry back the american wounded
every time the group came upon a german
position
york told the captured german major
to order the troops to surrender
the well-disciplined german soldiers
never questioned the order
and by the time york's small band
reached friendly lines
they had acquired 132 german prisoners
in their wake york's platoon left 35
deserted
german machine gun positions and a
significant gap in the german defenses
this gap which york had created was a
vital element to the success of the
division's advance
this advance gave momentum to the
american forces and contributed to the
success
of the offensive
phenomenal here's the lessons
corporal york was quick to exploit the
opportunity which had been created
he realized that his actions would
affect the outcome of the battalion's
advance and made decisions which
supported
his commander's intent his strong
situational awareness
guided him in taking action which had
decisive results
you know when you think even when i
think when i think of world war
one soldiers you i definitely envision
someone that's much more obedient than
what we have in the modern all-volunteer
military today
right you've got someone that's hey i
mean i would say the whole world was
more obedient right you had
a much more stringent class structure in
america
you had the much further separation
between the officers and the enlisted
and so so for this kid
to be like oh i got this
it's it's incredible it's incredible to
show that kind of initiative and i think
the fact that it was
in world war one is even more incredible
think about what what would happen if he
was just standing around waiting to be
told what to do in that situation though
which is what so many leaders we work
with think is the right call like
you should just wait to be told what to
do and then do you know carry on orders
without question
and uh and he would just be standing
there waiting to be told to do and and
they would fail and maybe the whole
offensive fails
as a result instead of someone who
actually understands the why
understands the commander's intent and
the purpose behind what what they're
trying to do
and can take the initiative to go make
things happen yeah you know what
uh i often say and i wrote about
i don't want yes men right i don't wanna
know someone that's just like yup
hey sounds good jocko sounds great you
know you want someone that's gonna push
back and like hey i don't agree with
that wait what about this
you take that one step further it's like
i want someone that's just gonna
figure out what to do and go freaking
execute it right that's what we want
that's what we're trying that's what we
want that's what we're trying to grow
that's what we're trying to
develop in our supported leadership is
that they're gonna
look even look beyond even look beyond
what i can see
and say oh i bet if i did this it would
be a good move
and maybe they're batting 80 percent i'm
good with that
i'd rather have somebody batting 80 on
80 good moves that took initiative and
made things happen and
20 of the time i got to go oh life hey
hold what you got man don't go over
there yet
much rather have that initiative
but that's something you've helped me
with as well though with
because i think it's a hard thing for a
lot of leaders to accept it's like well
you know we got to come up with the
right solution we don't want to make
mistakes and we want to
move forward and you know when you're
you're like listen
80 percent solutions that go 80
solutions to go right where if
we're never going to have a perfect plan
so let's let's get the plan
as close you know in a good direction
and then execute and execute and execute
and and have the initiative be default
aggressive uh i think i think that's
i know it can stifle me uh and i've
struggled with that
and i'm i'm not executing because i'm
trying to get it to the 97
solution you're like listen 80 solutions
start moving things forward execute
and i think that's very empowering to
think about that you don't have to have
the perfect plan
yeah you got to just go yeah very
liberating
to be like oh yeah i don't care about
that hey we we might not be oh yeah i
don't care
you know we well what if you don't care
about that dude
that hill over there yeah get there
well do you want me to have a logistics
i don't care about that i want
well do you want me to do it in the
daytime i don't care
well do you want no i don't care once
you get that hill
okay but let's do it the the point i'm
making here though is is
you know even whether it's echelon front
or working together and tasking a
bruiser
in in you know there can be something
like in my mind where i'm like hey you
know jacob's really good at this and i i
got to make sure that jocko and you know
has
like this is the right plan and it's
going to meet every single thing that
you know he wants to do so you start
putting these self-imposed restrictions
instead of like when you're like hey man
80 solutions go bro let's execute
and that that's it's super liberating to
think about it that way
and you realize like hey what i thought
you know i've got to get this thing
perfect so you know jack was like yeah
that's good
i actually don't and i'm actually i'm
actually failing if i'm not executing
and i'm
i'm sitting here trying to come up with
a perfect plan yeah there's uh some
report you were trying to get
and you were like hey you know what i
haven't gotten you this report because i
i can't quite figure out this little
detail at the end to make sure that it's
a hundred percent
and i just i i i'm just not getting it
to you because i don't want it to be
inaccurate
and i don't want to have you like pissed
and i was like
bro actually i remember exactly i said
have i ever sweated you for the details
on anything in the past
15 years and it was funny you you kind
of you tilted your head a little bit and
you went
nope and i was like why do you think i
would start sweating these little like
literally in meaningless meaningless
uh details and you're like roger i'm an
idiot cool got it
so no factor and that's a that is a
great example though because here i am
stewing about trying to put together a
multi-page report and you're like hey
bro just send me a
just just say hey i don't have the i
don't have all the information yet
here's what i think we're doing
here's kind of the general you know
direction we should go and as soon as
you said that i was like
just another reminder uh that it's
self-imposed restrictions and it's
it's really uh it can cause all kinds of
problems so yeah and and obviously that
means i'm doing a bad job of
you know telling you what the parameters
are
of success you know if i'm like hey can
you tell me what these numbers are
you're like cool yeah but it's going to
take me three weeks to dive into all
these details
if i was like hey and i you know i was
like hey dude i just need a little like
ballpark
where are we at okay got it because i
can give you that in 13 minutes
but you know it's the it goes back to
some of that
implied implied commander's intent right
because the implied commander's intent
is that
when i ask for something i need that
thing right
hey you know when jaclyn asks for
something because he doesn't ask for
much when he asks for something he must
want that thing
really exact the implied intent is that
i want the implied intent with me is
basically i want perfection right that's
that's that's a complete implied intent
and for some reason echo's never really
picked up on that
platform no no that's actually not true
if i think about it like the the way
there's been some things where i've seen
i found out after the fact what you did
to reach a level of
as close as a human can get to
perfection on something where i've been
like
i didn't expect him to do all that but
he did it so
that implied level of perfection
just from my own stupid personality is
like enough to make someone say well
i better get this right before you know
we go forward and
that sucks and and and i talked about it
at gettysburg
i was like you've got to think about
what your implied
what your implied commander's intent is
and if especially if you're going to ask
them to do something that's outside that
normal
implied commander's intent and you know
we talked about it with
general lee and some of his some of his
subordinate leaders that
hey general lee was about kicking ass so
we're moving here what's generally going
to want me to do he's going to want me
to kick ass
go forward but he said hey you know
don't go forward right now
but they get that word they're like yeah
but it's generally i'm gonna go get some
and they messed things up so you gotta
pay attention to that
implied commander's intent that just
your personality has
your own personality has a has a culture
to it
and you got to pay attention scary
that was a uh that was some rare praise
for for echo charles said we gotta note
that down
take a well-deserved well-deserved
obviously
thanks yeah yeah
i mean i'm thinking like the first time
we ever went to like
travel to do the podcast and you had
like a
and i expected i was like i had my
fingers crossed my toes crossed
my ears crossed hoping that you know all
this
quote all this equipment showed up and
we'd be able to you know we have
some guests come in and it's going to be
there the time is valuable and all this
stuff and i'm like thinking i hope this
and yeah you had it all you know in the
pelican case
yep everything was there i was like
right
away squared away which is not you know
maybe what everyone expects maybe some
people have a different implied
scenario all right
next one sergeant henry and that's i
haven't even said this yet that's what
this whole
manual is it's just anecdotal
one-page stories where the squad leader
makes a difference
sergeant henry hennigan u.s marine corps
haiti 1919 following serious
rebel uprisings the united states began
a prolonged occupation of haiti in 1915
charlemagne peralta was the leader of
the rebel
army known as cacos
the second marine brigade spent several
months in unsuccessful attempts to
topple charlemagne's group
henry hannikin a sergeant in the brigade
devised a bold plan
to separate charlemagne from the bulk of
his troops and ambush him
sergeant hannikin sent one of his most
reliable men to become a member of the
caicos
banned in a short period of time the
infiltrator
had earned the outlaws trust then
sergeant hannigan had his spy
feed the caicos location of a marine
unit that was vulnerable to attack
i'm going to talk about putting the bait
out there sends a little spy in there
and says hey there's going to be these
marines they're going to be vulnerable
to attack
henneken spy soon returned with
information of a rebel plan to attack
these marines
as well as charlemagne's location
during this attack on on 31 october 1919
sergeant hannigan led a 22 led 22 local
militiamen
in an attack on charlemagne disguised as
rebels this is
you know this is freaking getting it
disguised as rebels
hannikin and his unit moved through
several guard posts and boldly walked
into the unsuspecting rebel camp
when he was within 15 yards of you know
where this story is going
it's going right where you want it to go
when he was within 15 yards of
charlemagne
sergeant hannikin drew out his pistol
and shot and killed the rebel leader
in the firefight that followed dude in
the fire fight that followed
the small raiding party captured the
rebel position and defended it from a
series of counter-attacks
the marines who were the target of the
rebel attack had been warned by sergeant
hannikin of the impending strike and
were
well prepared for the rebel attack the
rebels were thoroughly defeated
the morning after his act after the
action sergeant hannigan reported his
exploits to his commanding officer
his commanding officer didn't even know
what he was doing he was just out there
getting after it hennigan's actions
had routed more than a thousand outlaws
killed their leader and virtually
shattered the entire bandit resistance
movement
in northern haiti for his actions
sergeant hennigan was awarded the medal
of honor
i mean what up
talking talk about taking commander's
intent and just running with it
default aggressive uh to the court right
that is like the
riskiest bunch of at of of actions right
hey i'm gonna set these guys over here
as bait i'm gonna sneak in there we're
gonna get dressed up as rebels
by the way when i get in there i'm just
gonna shoot this guy the first chance i
get
i i wonder had he had he had
uh some direction or approval from his
commanding officer if that would have
gotten approved
yeah no that's that's too risky don't do
it that that may have happened you know
i
every time i talk to tilt i'm like until
i'm sorry if i was in charge man i don't
know if i would have improved
any of your operations i'm going to go
24 miles into cambodia with
four other guys and we're gonna sit
around and wait to get attacked by a
freaking division of nva soldiers
okay cool let's do it you know as i
think about that though a lot of people
obviously you can be too aggressive
right we got to be default aggressive
but not not
not too aggressive not reckless and it
sounds like they they mitigated the risk
they needed to obviously it was
successful you know in that regard but
i think what a lot of leaders miss is
and really we
we got a lot of scrutiny on our pretty
bold and aggressive operations in ramadi
back in 2006 is that by being default
aggressive you can actually mitigate
risk
so by by going into areas where the the
enemy
there were insurgent neighborhoods that
no no one else could get into they had
no u.s or coalition forces presence
they had no expectation we were going to
be there so we'd show up in places that
would catch them off guard they
we had the initiative they didn't and it
sounds like that's exactly what happened
in that situation
and i think some leaders you got to
think about that look you can actually
mitigate risk by being default
aggressive
and something that you know you were uh
you were all about attacking a bruiser
and i think we utilized our advantage
were you in the chow hall
in the in the camp mark lee chow hall
like early in deployment when our
commanding officer was talking to me
and he says you know what about all
these these guys with ieds because i was
telling them that we were going to be
going on patrols and it's going to be
very dangerous
and he said what are you going to do
about these ieds and these guys that are
putting ieds in the ground
and i go we're going to kill them and
that was my
mitigation plan which is a very good
mitigation plan
get in a position where you can kill
those guys so your overwatch team sets
up and you got people patrolling you
kill the bad guys
and he was like okay sounds like a good
plan
right and and yes and that that's an
example of
how are you going to stay safe by being
aggressive that's
absolutely true well just okay take the
id threat
as an example right if if we're
patrolling to an area where they have no
expectation we're going to be there
the locals are out on the street i mean
there's we're actually much safer from
ieds than we are if we're
rolling down routes rolling down the
main route where they're expecting it to
u.s forces to be and that's
i think that's a great example in in our
ceo's mind it's like how do we do this
this is dangerous and
and i think actually thinking it's
actually less dangerous to be super
aggressive
and to be someplace where they have no
expectation versus them sitting back and
waiting to ideas
where they know we're going to be
lessons sergeant hannikin displayed
outstanding initiative
that's the understatement of the year
and tactical proficiency
okay maybe that's the understatement
here in devising
and acting upon a plan to defeat a large
rebel force his plan supported the
brigade
the brigade's mission in haiti sergeant
anakin accepted great risk but displayed
the courage and nerve to see his plan
through his bold action achieved
decisive
results with a small band of men
sergeant hannigan was able to defeat a
larger rebel force by adhering to
tactical fundamentals
his 22-man main effort attacked the
enemy center of gravity
the rebel leader without leadership the
rebel force
quickly disintegrated sergeant hannikin
used the elements of surprise and
deception
to execute his attack surprise is one of
the most important tactical fundamentals
and was essential to this tactical
undertaking sergeant anakin's
actions illustrate how tactical
decisions at the squad level
can impact the operational and strategic
levels of war
and can ultimately affect u.s policy
sergeant hanek's attack greatly affected
the balance of power in haiti lessening
the turmoil in the country
it was a major step towards ending the
rebellion on the island
so there you go it's a strategic move
and
we always try and point out to companies
that your frontline troops can have a
negative strategic impact or a positive
strategic impact
and it's even that's even more
accentuated in this day and age now that
we have
social media and you can have one
employee at one of your stores
either do something horrible and and
really
damage your reputation or do something
heroic and really help your reputation
so do you have you in place the culture
that's going to drive those frontline
people to do something heroic or
have you got a culture where they're
going to be driven to do something
horrible
i don't know that's on you your team
the prospect of surprise is always the
surest guarantee
of victory that's from
von melinthin who's a world war ii
general
he wrote the book panzer battles which
we haven't gotten to
yet on the podcast we'll get there
no tactical action should ever be
undertaken without the element of
surprise
speaking of germans this here i already
thought this book was going to be about
marines
and now we already have army marine i
certainly thought it was going to be
about americans this is about a german
so the
the marine corps attitude is wide open
sergeant wenzel german army belgium
1940. the german plan to invade france
included the invasion of belgium and
holland
the french had not defended their border
with belgium leaving it open to attack
the belgians however had constructed a
series of forts along the canals
throughout the countryside the most
formidable of these was
even a male manned by
1200 belgian soldiers the powerful guns
of
even a male commanded the eastern
approaches to the belgian border
if this fortress was not eliminated the
german army would have
significant difficulty crossing the
belgian border
sergeant wenzel was a member of
germany's parachute forces
must've been rad being a parish trooper
in world war ii
you're the cutting edge of tech i mean
what a few years earlier
it wasn't even an idea that you could
huck a person out of a plane with a
piece of with a freaky piece of cloth
above them and they'd live
and here they are just doing assaults
this one they weren't paratrooping
actually
on 10 may 1940 his paratroop company
daringly landed on the top of even
a male in gliders with the mission of
silencing the guns of the fortress in
order to allow the german army to
capture bridges to the east when
sergeant wenzel landed atop the fortress
he realized his commanding officer's
glider had not made it to the objective
this left sergeant wenzel in command of
80 parachutists
in four-man teams the germans used
flamethrowers and
special-shaped charges to attack each
gun turret
sergeant wenzel commanded his unit from
a captured pillbox
the situation became tenuous when the
belgians prevented the german
reinforcements from arriving by blowing
the bridge on the main route
of the ground attack the paratroopers
were cut off the belgians were also
calling artillery on the germans
and enemy infantry could be seen
preparing to counter-attack the
paratroopers
and as i was reading this i was like
wait a second enemy who are we talking
about they're talking about the belgians
sergeant wenzel continued to lead the
parachutists for three more hours
as each belgian gun position was
eliminated after the sun had set
sergeant wenzel linked up with german
forces from the east
even a male had fallen sergeant wenzel's
actions
allowed german forces approaching from
the east to advance unmolested across
the canals
with a force of 80 men he had subdued
of the enemy
the defense of belgium was broken and
the german army was able to rapidly
defeat belgium
and move into france the northern wing
of the german army
rapidly out flanked the french army and
brought about a defeat to the french
forces in a mere six weeks
for his heroic actions and outstanding
leadership sergeant wenzel was awarded
the knights cross
when you think about 80 men
beating hundred i was sitting here
in my mind i'm thinking how do you even
do that but then
you have probably heard me say
don't dig in don't get in a position
where you can't get out of
well if you set up a fort where you're
all in bunkered positions
and all of a sudden the enemy gets in
there and they can maneuver really
quickly
and you're stuck in this pillbox or
you're stuck in this gun emplacement
while the other while you're bad guys
the people that are trying to kill you
are running around and sneaking around
and
can get free fields of fire because
you're stuck in this box that's that's
in my mind how it happens i but you do
have to recognize that even a male was
probably the most
im impregnable force fortress monster
freaking monster it was like i think 200
foot high walls along
crazy i mean so they they probably felt
like completely safe
no factor there's no way the germans are
coming but i i think what's crazy when
we talk about the omen surprise in that
situation the germans knew they were
coming i mean there was an attack coming
obviously the german the germans knew
they were coming they had every expert
you mean the belgians knew that they
were coming i'm sorry the belgians do
the
yes i'm sorry the belgians knew the
germans were coming so the belgians
they they they didn't have the um the
germans did not have the element of
surprise there because the
the but they didn't know the manner in
which the attack was coming
and i think technology played a key role
because
i i believe that might have been the
first use of glyphosate combat
ever uh if i remember that correctly it
was certainly one of the first if
not the first and so they they didn't
have the expectation that they could
land on top of this fortress
it was also the first use i think of
shape charges uh as well or that was an
invented a brand new technology
so they felt safe in these giant
caissons of you know concrete and steel
and uh i think what an amazing victory
of of of just
being default aggressive to the core
hitting him
even when they expected that the attack
was coming uh they didn't realize the
manner in which it was coming and i
think they just overwhelmed them with
now they're in the fortress and we felt
safe what do we do now
you know yeah and i think well the the
technical i guess definition of
surprise
because you know if if in jiu jitsu
right you know you're going for an arm
lock
you know you're going for an arm lock
you know i'm trying to tap you out right
you know i'm trying to tap you out you
know i'm trying to tap you out so i'm
grabbing your neck and
you're you're you know i'm trying to
grab your neck and boom i go for your
arm right so it's a surprise
even though you know i'm trying to tap
you out i'm still gonna surprise you
it's like a
similar thing right we know we're gonna
get attacked but what are these
weird quiet winged things coming from
the sky
and why are they filled with people 80
people
versus 1200 that's freaking insane
lessons sergeant wenzel realized that
it was his responsibility to complete
the mission after his commanding
officers
glider failed to land on the fortress
how's that guy feeling
afterwards
he's like so uh
bummed lucky if he was still alive he's
still alive
he worked with the existing plan and
took advantage of the element of
surprise
that his airborne landing had given him
taking charge of 80 men sergeant wentzel
showed out sending leadership and
courage as he commanded the efforts
against the fortress for three hours
against great odds sergeant wenzel's
understanding of the plan allowed him to
shoulder the burden of responsibility of
leading the assault force
he clearly understood his pivotal role
in the invasion of belgium
and his actions fully supported his
commander's intent
sergeant wenzel's company level raid
permitted a regimental
river crossing which in turn allowed the
german army to rapidly pour into belgium
this eventually led to the fall of both
belgium and france so there you go
totally pivotal
moment one thing i wanted to
say i don't disagree with you very often
there but uh
yeah it would from a personal
perspective you're like man i'm so
bummed i wasn't there wasn't able to
lead that
but actually from a leadership
perspective you should be absolutely
stoked oh yeah that you're absolutely
you're
frontline leaders stop stood up made
things happen got the job done
even without you there and obviously
that's the the real testament
of leadership that it's about the
mission it's not about you yeah yeah no
it's uh
the uh on a personal level of course the
guy's bummed on a professional level
he's totally stoked and yeah obviously
on a personal level you're like freaking
totally stoked that your
front line troops got the job done while
you were uh
you know while you were in some vineyard
somewhere drinking wine
i i will say uh as as a couple of times
that i was acting
tasked a commander in tasking a bruiser
while there was some huge operation
going on with most of charlie platoon
and
del platoon you were out in the
battlefield i was like this is not fun
see that's
says here ends this one of the quote it
is not the big armies that win battles
it is the good ones
[Music]
that's field marshall maurice
the sax which born in 1696 podcast 110
we covered his book and he's a weird
he's got a weird background he's all
kinds of things
he was like polish and german and french
and and served in the imperial roman
army but
he wrote that book i think it's my
reveries on the war
it's a good book podcast 110. he's got
the title field marshall though that's
pretty cool
remember we had a uh in task and bruiser
we had it we had a captain obvious
and uh and so he he was kind of over the
top with like the obvious comments so we
promoted him to admiral obvious
and then it kind of went beyond that i
was like look what sounds even cooler or
bigger
so he became field martial obviously
yeah there's only been
i mean as far as i know at least in the
in the u.s navy there's been only been
one
field marshal of the obvious
which is a big promotion you know it's a
big promotion it's almost like a five
star
it's be honest it's beyond that's not
quite a five star but it's definitely
you are definitely putting out some
obvious stuff
you don't want to be field martial
obviously
not a compliment it's weird too because
you'd think when you got
when you caught you know captain obvious
right when you catch that nickname
you're going to start
maybe paying attention right putting
yourself in check when you get promoted
what was the next promotion when you get
promoted to admiral obviously like all
right this is definitely gotta stop
i gotta just just just bite my lip a
little bit more
still don't still don't quite pull it
off guess what
once you're field marshall well i think
once you field marshall own it
right own it hey i got a real couple
obvious points to point out
sergeant rhubarth back-to-back german
army
france 1940 in the spring of 1940 the
german army invaded france as the
campaign
campaign progressed the 10th panzer
division was directed to cross the muse
river
and continue to attack toward paris
the french realized that the river
provided a natural obstacle
that could be used to halt the advancing
germans sergeant rhubarth
the leader of a squad of assault
engineers which was attached to the
german 69th infantry regiment the
germans were
the germans controlled the east side of
the river and the french were dug in on
the west
the french defenses included artillery
and machine gun bunkers all along the
river
after a violent stuka air attack
sergeant rhubarth
squad attacked with infantry as his
rubber boat reached the far
shore sergeant rhubarth's squad attacked
and destroyed the nearest bunker on
reassembling his squad sergeant rhubarth
realized only two boats had successfully
crossed the river
leaving only his squad and one infantry
squad on the west shore
to create a breach in the french
defenses how many people are supposed to
go
assault engineers i wonder how many
boats they actually had
only two made it okay undaunted
he ordered his unit to attack another
bunker with grenades
and a satchel charge the french soldiers
inside
surrendered and their white flag was
replaced with german colors
this drew cheers from the germans on the
far side of the river
and demoralized the french defenders
sergeant rhubarth then advanced and
aggressively took two more bunkers
creating a mere 300 meter gap in the
first line of french defenses
more german forces then followed him
across the river after receiving a fresh
supply of ammunition
and four more men don't worry you got
four more men
proceed sergeant rhubarth continued his
attack and
as enemy artillery started raining down
on them sergeant rhubarth moved his
squad quickly so that the artillery fire
could not adjust to them
his squad overtook three more bunkers
and broke through the second line of
enemy positions the second line of enemy
positions
after seeing several of their bunkers
blown up the french forces assumed that
they were being overrun
their spirit crushed the french began to
withdraw
the action became a route as the
advancing german pursued
germans pursued the french forces for
his achievement sergeant rhubarth
received a battlefield commission to
lieutenant as awarded
the knighthood of the iron cross
when i think now thinking to that the
last one in this one
let's face it you got a small number of
guys and you just start going
ham just start attacking and people
aren't expecting you to do that right
they don't expect
they see two boats show up they're like
oh whatever and then all of a sudden
their bunker's getting
you know shaped charged on it and you're
getting jacked up
going and moving quicker than these
people that are in these
static positions this is maneuver
warfare right this is like the beginning
of maneuver warfare i can move and you
can't
just think of that think of that and
then think of it from a leadership
perspective
think of it when you say this is what we
need to do
and now you've just dug into your
position you can't move anywhere
and malay says hey jocko i know that's
what you want to do but what about
you know what about this over here with
these other clients and i go
[Music]
we're sticking to the plan right it just
doesn't work whereas i'm like hey
this is where i'm at right now what do
you guys think or this is where we're at
right now
but we might have to flex that's all you
need to say that's all you need to say
is hey
i have an open mind that's all you need
to do is have an open mind
present your idea with uh with an out
right
take your position but give yourself an
out that's all you need to do
so you can maneuver a little bit i
i think that mentality like from a
defensive perspective you know i know
cloudsmiths talked about the defensive
position being
you know the strongest and and your
mentality is like
you know you're giving all the momentum
all the initiative
uh and i think particularly when you're
in a fortune where it's even a male or
you know this
these positions they probably had no
expectation that someone could be inside
their fortress oh we're totally safe
here we're totally good to go we have
the advantage
and so as soon as that happens i mean
that doubt starts to creep in like
man i you know you're you're done
they've they've lost they've lost all
morale people ready to surrender people
ready to retreat i think that's
there's something about just being on
the advance that gives you
i think all the advantage in the world
did you when i was talking about the
fact that they raised the german flag
and that helped morale
i had a vision of a certain american
flag going up in random buildings over
the city of ramadi sometimes
i don't know what you're talking about
boss
i think that was very helpful for morale
i could see the point or deny
that uh that the uh the american flag
was run up well
you know you talk about hey we're going
in there and you know we get approval
for these missions like
you know we're gonna be a sneaky sniper
overwatch we don't want the bad guys to
know where we are
a couple times we just just had to run
the old stars and strikes up in the
middle of the city and say we're right
here bring it
and uh we did get uh in fact dave burke
called me on the radio good deal dave
good deal did call me on the radio to
pass the word to us in one particular
position that
hey there were some troops massing and i
was like bring it on
this is that that's exactly what we're
hoping for mass attack
bring it on good morale
for the troops i don't know if that
could have gotten it it was like
plausible deniability for uh
jocko his task at a commander there we
didn't exactly run that one up for
well i guess there was some indication
because uh well
since we're putting ourselves on report
here we weren't you weren't allowed to
fly an american flag
period and we did have a american flag
on cam mark lee 24 7 over time
affirmative so maybe my
implied commander's intent was if you
gotta run up the stars and stripe
if you got to run up the stars and
stripes make it tall
make it tall and have a lot of machine
guns pointing in all directions which we
did
check lessons
sergeant rhubarth clearly understood the
importance of rapid
crossing of the river
the commander's intent at all levels
from squad to division was to cross the
river quickly in order to maintain the
momentum of attack
a delay at the river would have given
the french time to strengthen positions
closer to paris
and possibly hold the german offensive
so that's a great that's a really good
simple
example of commander's intent to say hey
listen
the commander's intent of this operation
is we have to get across this river as
quickly as possible
and now everybody in your division knows
we're going to get across this river
that's the goal and we'll do whatever i
got to do to make that happen that's a
very nice
clear example of what a commander's
intent is
now everybody now everybody knows what
we're trying to do
and if something changes or the enemy
does something i don't expect guess what
cool i'm going to adapt i'm going to get
across this river i'm going to take as
many of my guys with me as i can
taking on the role as the main effort of
the german attack sergeant rhubarth
displayed outstanding leadership
shouldering the responsibility of
creating
a breach in the french defenses though
greatly outnumbered on the far shore the
squad followed their courageous and
decisive leader
sergeant rhubarth's bravery and judgment
allowed him to succeed
despite being isolated and under attack
by french artillery
sergeant rhubarth did not wait for
reinforcements but continued to attack
the enemy deciding that rapid action was
necessary
this is where action versus inaction
right action versus inaction
what was i saying yesterday when we were
recording ef online
i was i was like nine times out of ten
action is better than in action this is
an example now is there a case where
perhaps it would be
better to wait for reinforcements but
i'll tell you what here's the deal
if you take action you know what we got
enough guys what we're going to push
we're going to go
maybe you get stopped maybe you meet
heavy resistance
now you know that now you know you
actually can't proceed but if you go and
you're like hey actually we just
we just took another bunker let's take
another one
you take small steps you go forward you
take action and then you learn from the
feedback if the feedback would have been
hey we just tried to take another bunker
and we got
shellacked okay well we're not going to
move anymore we're going to wait for
reinforcements
fine what should your default mode be be
aggressive
make it happen
his actions create an opportunity which
his commanders took advantage of by
pouring forces through the breach and
decisively defeating the enemy sergeant
rhubard's actions contributed
directly to his battalion's crossing his
divisions attacked and the eventual
defeat of france
five weeks later
far better it is quote far better it is
to dare mighty things to win glorious
triumphs even though
checkered by failure than to rank with
those poor spirits who neither enjoy
much nor that neither enjoy much nor
suffer defeat
because they live in the gray twilight
that knows not victory or defeat
and that's teddy roosevelt
medal of honor cuba his son medal of
honor utah beach
all right next up the marine corps
brings it we got we got sergeant john
basilone u.s marine corps guadalcanal
august 1942 the first marine division
landed on guadalcanal
encountering stiff resistance from the
japanese defenders sergeant
john bazalone served as a machine gun
platoon sergeant in support of
company c 1st battalion 7th marines
on the night of 24 october sergeant
basilone's platoon
occupied a key position in the
battalion's offensive perimeter on a
jungle ridge
just past 2130 the japanese began a
ferocious attack in the dark rainy night
intense fighting followed and soon the
machine gun unit on basilone's right
was overrun by screaming japanese
soldiers hurling
grenades and firing rifles
at the same time basilone's machine guns
started running low on ammunition
basilone knew that the enemy that had
broken through on his right were between
him and the ammunition dump
but he decided that if his gun teams
were not resupplied
the positions would fall sergeant
bazillon
took off his heavy mud caked boots
stripped himself of all
unnecessary gear and sprinted down the
trail
after returning with several belts of
ammunition he set out for the unmanned
machine gun pits to his right knowing
that those heavy weapons were vital
tools in the defense of the ridge when
he got back to the gun positions
he found two unoccupied machine guns
jammed and ran
back to get one of his own he ordered a
team to follow him
after bazillon's gun crew reached their
destination he immediately put them into
action
basilone lay on the ground and began
repairing one of the damaged weapons
once the gun was repaired and loaded he
got behind the gun and began engaging
targets the fight raged on and japanese
bodies
began to pile up in front of the machine
guns at one point sergeant basilone
had to direct his marines to push back
the piles of bodies
to maintain clear fields of fire
several more times during the night
sergeant basilone made trips
back to the command area for desperately
needed ammunition
eight separate attacks were sent against
the marines that night
and basilone's platoon fired over 25
000 rounds
they were credited with killing an
estimated 300 enemy soldiers
playing a major role in thwarting the
japanese attack
this successful defense re-established
the perimeter
of the first marine division protected
the vital airfield
and led to the conquest of guadalcanal
the first island taken from the japanese
[Music]
for his initiative resourcefulness and
leadership in defense of the ridge
sergeant bazalon was awarded the medal
of honor
lessons tactically sergeant basilone
understood his role in the defense of
the ridge and the intent of the company
and battalion commanders his machine gun
served a pivotal role in the company and
battalion defense line
plan he took numerous actions necessary
to ensure his battalion's
success this included making the
decision to weaken one position in order
to fortify
an adjacent unit's position to his right
sergeant basilone exhibited great
leadership during the defense
he went to great lengths to provide his
unit with whatever tools were necessary
to maintain the defense of the ridge
his courage in braving enemy fire to
deliver ammunition
set an example for his marines
unbelievable it's it's interesting
when you think about they're low on
ammunition
and his decision is i'm going to get
i'm going to go personally get the
ammunition and i can see a couple
factors playing into that decision
one of them being if we don't have ammo
we're all gonna die
so it doesn't matter you know i could
send another guy
but and i could stay here to try and
help you know
maintain our position but without
without ammunition we're all going to
die
so the number one thing we need
is ammunition and these guys know what
they're doing they got this
but without bullets we're gonna get
overrun i'm going to do this
that's a it's an interesting thing
because
you know sometimes a leader's got to say
okay this is what's going on here's the
absolutely critical task and i'm
actually just going to go do it right
now
because if it doesn't get done we're all
doomed
taking off his boots that's a
that's hard thing for me to think about
because my feet are soft
man i think every time we turned on
basil on road
you know up there at camp pendleton
going our ranges and
and training uh you just think about
think about uh you know the exploits of
john basil that's that's incredible i
you know i think
the other thing too to think about here
is these other these other illustrations
we're looking at i mean obviously
amazing illustrations of
a junior leader you know squad leader
stepping up and making these calls but
you know the previous ones in world war
one and two uh you were talking about
you know
look vicious fighting obviously people
are dying and and
being uh you know shot and blown up or
banned or whatever but
those particular charges bonsai charges
like that in uh in guadalcanal like
there's
zero quarters gonna be given so you're
overrun and like everyone's gonna get
killed
and and i think uh you know i think that
was
uh it's a different situation you know
uh and i think
a lot more desperation there you can't
just throw up your hands and surrender
like the germans did to sergeant
or corporal york in that particular
situation yeah i mean i almost didn't
even make it past the sentence in the
dark rainy night intense fighting
followed and soon
the machine gun unit on basilone's right
was overrun by
screaming japanese soldiers hurling
grenades and firing rifles
just dark and
when you're in dark and especially in a
jungle like that and it's dark outside
and then you shoot your gun and now
you've seen the muzzle flash
like you can't you can't see anything
now like it's dark it's black and
so now the only thing you're hearing is
screaming japanese
they're throwing grenades which again is
ruining your night vision
you're seeing muzzle flashes you're
shooting back at muzzle flashes
freaking just horror it's just horror
yeah that's that's some unbelievable
heroism there
i i think you're hitting on a good point
though about prior the prioritizing
execute piece and i think you know we
generally would say leaders don't want
to be down in the details you want to be
detached but
you know to your point if you in the
prioritizing execute scene if i don't go
do this now
none of it matters we have to do that
and uh
it's the existential priority if if we
don't
execute this priority we will not exist
anymore it's an
existential decision and there's only
you look and he probably looked
said you know i got this guy he's
working that gun
he can do that there's one person that
could actually make this happen right
now and it's me
i'll be back in seven minutes with some
ammo fellas
bazzy
next up sergeant jacob pavlov
russian army stalingrad 1942
in the fall of 1942 the german sixth
army was pushing into the russian city
of stalingrad
the russian strategy was to draw the
germans into the city and fight them
from building to building
sergeant jacob pavlov of the soviet 13th
guard division
was called into his battalion map room
in order to recon
a four-story house in order to develop a
company plan to attack the building
that night sergeant pavlov selected
three men from his squad and set
out on the reconnaissance so hey go into
a recon to this building
so that we can do a company size 150 man
assault on this building when the
four-man team reached the objective
sergeant pavlov realized that the house
was occupied by only a few german
defenders
he decided to seize the house
immediately with his small team he
quickly devised a plan
and within minutes had attacked and
taken control of the house
using captured german machine guns and
their own tommy guns
sergeant pavlov led his men in fighting
back
wave after wave of german
counter-attacks the next night sergeant
pavlov
sent a messenger back to his battalion
by morning his group was reinforced with
16 men
three anti-tank rifles two mortars and
more machine guns
his defensive preparations continued he
directed the placement of a minefield
around the building he ordered his men
to take out the interior walls of the
building to allow freedom of movement
he posted sharpshooters and observers in
the top of the building and fortified
his command post
a 200 yard trench was dug for resupply
when the german that's a lot of
things to get done digging a 200 yard
trench
is no joke what is that digging a 200
yard trench
and posting sharp shorters and removing
the walls inside the building so you
have better freedom of movement this guy
was not playing
when the german sent larger armored
forces
against him sergeant pavlov in
improvised new tactics to fight them
this is beautiful due to the limited
elevation of the german tanks
pavlov sent his machine gunners to the
top floors and his anti-tank crews to
the basement
from these positions his men put
accurate suppressing fire on the german
infantry while destroying the army
of the armor so a tank gun can only go
so far up and so far down
and apparently they couldn't go far
enough up to hit the roof where the
machine gunners were and couldn't go far
enough down
to hit the anti-tank weapons
pavlov's house proved to be a key
russian position in the battle for
stalingrad
the building's height allowed pavlov's
observers to call accurate artillery
fire in
any direction and snipers chalked up
hundreds of kills
from the attic
upon finding his object this is the
lessons upon finding his objective
lightly defended sergeant pavlov ignored
his orders
and used his initiative to take the
house by surprise
this key decision fully submit supported
his commander's intent now
what's interesting about this is we dig
in a little bit
if i was sending you leif to go and do a
recon of a building that we were going
to attack tomorrow with
150 men
i might not even cover the contingency
we might not even cover the contingency
of hey
if there's no one in there just take it
like because you're not expecting
if you're expecting to need 150 people
you're not expecting that four people
so you might not even consider that hey
and by the way if there's
light resistance just take it because
even light resistance with four guys
going into a defended position it's
going to be hard
all you need is one person with a
machine gun at the end of a hallway and
you got real problems
so the fact that he just said
i think we hey i think we got this
right get it done and and and there's no
radios
there's no radios they're not calling up
and saying hey hey jockle this is life i
took the building
send reinforcements no you're just there
oh you said he sent a messenger the next
day four hours later after you hold
station for 24 hours
with four guys that's that's crazy
that's that's the power though of the
commander's intent you know
understanding the why and i think
if you and certainly i mean the culture
in the soviet army that time was was
pretty centralized
uh you know as far as decisions to be
made so i i can't imagine that he got
briefed
for that contingency i think that's
highly unlikely
so someone just to be like hey but think
think about what happens here though if
he goes back
you know he goes back and says hey
there's only you know it's the only
resistance there we can attack now and
maybe maybe by the time they plan their
attack and 24 hours later it's
reinforced and there's 200 people there
you know instead of a dozen or whatever
it was
so that's uh that's pretty amazing
initiative to say okay
what they actually what we want to do
strategically is take this this key
piece of terrain and i'm going to take
it
right now because there there's the
initiative here's there's the
opportunity in front of me
and you know to seize the initiative
that's that's incredible let's get it
that's leroy jenkins just showed up in
stalingrad
leroy jacobs
but think about that though from a
perspective leaders they they don't
you think that you don't want your
people to do that i don't want them to
go too far i don't want to get too
too aggressive i don't want to you know
you you wait for my orders and
and so so there are plenty of leaders
who would be upset
with a squad leader like pavlov
executing on something like that instead
of actually saying
that's awesome and if i had a bunch of
path loves we're gonna we're gonna win
this thing
yeah and that it's gonna make all the
difference i i used to tell the
the task unit commanders and then i tell
the whole task unit
but i pulled the task into commander's
side and say hey
you know there'd be chaos going on and
they wouldn't be getting anywhere they'd
be bogged down they'd be getting shot up
with paintball those problems would be
happening during training
and i'd say imagine if each one of your
fire team leaders was doing something
smart
to move you where you wanted to go
imagine how easy things would be and
they'd look at me like
dumbfounded because they'd know that's
true
like let's face it if a fireteam leader
goes hey we got a wounded guy we need to
move him and
the boss just said we're moving south to
the rally point if we all know we're
moving south to raleigh point
every fire team can can start to make
that happen and that was one of the
things that would
help help move a task unit from
centralized command to decentralized
command just that little conversation
which i had dozens of times
hey what do you think how do you think
it would be if every one of your
fire team leaders right now was doing
something
that you wanted them to do that was good
that was
moving them towards your goal how how do
you think that would affect you right
now they'd be like
it would be very helpful and i'd be like
yes it would be why don't you tell them
all what that overall goal is right now
you're in the perimeter everyone's
everyone's within 50 meters
you could actually just yell it out
right now we're moving south to rally
point
alpha let's go okay cool
maybe one fire team leader looks at
another fire team leader and says hey
i got cover you bound back all right
that's two that's it that's eight guys
moving in the right direction
some other fire team leader goes hey
we're good we got dead space let's move
okay that's another
four guys movie see you just need to
think that way
you need your team to go out and make
things happen but they can only do that
if they know where they're going
i watched you have the the other side of
that equation as well
you know which is something we talk
about a lot of echelon fraud and that's
when we would see the the the
recognition in these young leaders
of the power of leadership and whether
it was a fire team leader or a squad
leader
or a machine gunner a machine gunner who
wasn't in charge of anybody else
and they're standing out in the street
in this total you know this mount town
the
urban urban you know training
environment and there's paintballs
flying around and explosions going off
and total chaos
and and uh that was it was so much like
the leadership laboratory that you
always talk about was just an incredible
thing to watch
and when i was out there you know my my
last command as a senior leader just
observing my
my team and being there with you uh as
as your your uh
your mentoring and training folks and
walking up to some some machine gunners
and hey uh
what's going on right now they're like i
don't know what's going on somebody
doesn't make a call this is ridiculous
what do you what do you what do you
think you should do right now we should
get in that building over there
why don't you make it happen i remember
i'd get the bla this is
the blank stare of like wait a second
you're telling me that
i could get people to go over there and
they look at me kind of tilt the head
and say i'm gonna get in trouble if i do
that i can't do that
actually no one is doing anything right
now i just walked by
your platoon commander and he was
sitting there talking to your task unit
commander
about spaghetti for dinner because they
have no idea what's happening
and if you don't make something happen
no one's going to be eating anything
tonight because we're going to do this
over and over again
well but you would ask the question like
hey do you think your dad's getting
commander wants you to be sitting out in
the street getting shot right now
and the answer is of course not of
course they don't want they're tied up
with some other problem
or their spaghetti dinner or whatever it
is
but once you once they recognize the
power of leadership and you encourage
them to make that call and they're like
hey
fall back in the building and now all of
a sudden you've got leaders at every
level that are stepping up and making
things happen
so so you having both of those
conversations with the leaders
both ends to encourage encourage their
their junior folks to step up and make
calls and then
with the the junior frontline troops
that are executing
and then you actually have decentralized
command that's out there making things
happen
it's a powerful powerful tool
decentralized command sergeant back to
the book sergeant pavlov
showed exceptional leadership skills
while defending the house he organized
and led an effective defensive position
for
over six weeks
he showed tactical improvisation and
skill
as a combined arms leader sergeant
pavlov's actions show how one leaders
actually can contribute to an overall
battle his platoon sized
defensive strong point became the key
position for his battalion which in turn
became the main effort of the division
freaking awesome it's better to be it's
better to be on hand with 10 men
than to be absent with 10 000. that's
from
tamerlane a mongol emperor
that would uh that would be uh
genghis khan or genghis khan
[Music]
uh what that mongol emperor
no it's not him is it not it's not him
it's not him i don't even actually know
if those two were related
but same area of the earth that's for
damn sure
and apparently apparently both of them
are like kicking ass
what was what was what was genghis
khan's real name
i thought it was no it's not it um it's
i gotta go back and review the book i
read a few years ago you're right it
does begin with like a team
and they make they made some kind of a
movie about it echo that maybe you could
help out here there's a movie about it
dude that's a week for neither one of us
to be able to talk about right
more discipline go but i know that
that's not him
um all right
sergeant thornton british army france
vital to the success i like i said that
life just pounded something
i need to remember that name let's bring
the clarity
vital to the success of the 1944 allied
invasion of europe was the capture of
valuable bridges inland of the beaches
this was to be done by parachute forces
the night before d-day if these bridges
were not taken
the german army would be able to
counter-attack the landing forces and
push the allies into the sea
just after midnight in the early morning
hours of 6 june the 5th parachute
brigade of this
british 6 airborne division landed in
normandy one glider company
was tasked with the vital mission of
seizing and holding
the pegasus bridge which crossed
the kane canal
and secure the east flank of the british
landing beaches
if this bridge was not secured the
germans would be able to launch a flank
attack
into the exposed left wing of the
british invasion of forces
after seizing the bridge in a daring
assault the company established a
defensive perimeter
facing east towards an intersection at
0-132 tanks of the first panzer
engineer company with infantry support
crept toward the bridge
as the lead element of a german
counter-attack the only
this is a good story the only anti-tank
weapon available to the platoon
covering this approach was a small piat
rocket manned by sergeant thornton
the paratroopers were fearful that a
tank attack could not be stopped
sergeant thornton laid lay hidden in a
pile of equipment
knowing the limited range of the piat
and the vulnerability of his platoon's
position
he decided to wait until the tanks were
a mere 50 yards away before firing
thornton fired the piat gun and scored a
direct hit on the lead
tank the round penetrated and caused a
magnificent explosion
shells inside the tank began to cook off
creating a fantastic light show
the german company commander was
mortally wounded as he tried to flee the
burning hulk
the display and numerous explosions
acted as a beacon for other paratroop
forces
lost in the dark they converged on
pegasus bridge
believing that british forces had come
under severe attack
the second german tank immediately
reversed course
the lieutenant in the tank reported that
the british had occupied the bridge in
force
and were equipped with six pound
anti-tank guns
the german commanders decided to wait
until daylight before launching another
attack
as morning approached the allied forces
were able to land on the normandy
beaches and protect
from a strong german counterattack the
german delay allowed the allies to build
up combat power on the beaches and
rapidly strike inland
the invasion of france and the drive
across europe led to the defeat
of germany in less than a year's time
so some lessons here sergeant thornton
knew that his piat gun was the only
defense
that paratroopers had against the german
army he decided to hold his fire until
the lead tank was danger close luring
the germans into a trap
this is legit that is that is badass
right there
you got to think what's going through
that guy's mind i mean just being in
close proximity to tanks
in iraq 50 yards away
and just that noise and knowing the
power of that thing
and you know and you know his guys are
like dude what is what's he waiting for
yeah and the time you got that thought
going through your head of like the
catty shack like
noonan like don't miss yeah you got one
shot one shot
to quote uh the great echo charles all
you could say is
dang yeah that's a tough one
when sergeant thornton's round hit the
tank it set off a chain of events which
helped ensure the success of the d-day
invasion the british were able to
reinforce
and reconsolidate in the dark the
germans decided not to risk a knight
attack against strong unknown forces the
burning tank itself
prevented the germans from approaching
the bridge when the british
when the brit with the bridge in british
hands the paratroop company held an
entire panzer regiment at bay
damn if that panzer regiment had been
able to penetrate into normandy
into the normandy beachhead the ally
invasion might have failed
the company's pivotal position supported
the airborne divisions mission and
allowed the british landing
forces to free access to the beaches
one shot potentially shaved the left
flank
of the allied invasion one shot saved
the left flank of the allied invasion
and there's a comment here
a tactical success is only really
decisive
if it is gained at the strategically
correct spot
that's which we haven't done him yet but
we got him in the books
all right so while i was reading that
i thought of something so
i was talking about the fact earlier
that
when we got to modern warfare when we
got machine guns
we started to decentralize command
because now
leif's squad is 100 yards away from me
so that way we have some dispersions
that we all
we all don't get killed at the same time
so that way i just got to say hey like
leif here's our objective you got to go
make it happen
so now when you're talking about going
in right like you're going into gliders
and it's in
in bander brothers when you're watching
the gliders come in
you're going in the dark you're hitting
you're just you're just gonna be alone
when you hit the ground
that's what's gonna happen you're gonna
be with what you're gonna be with
whatever 22 other guys
that's what you're going to be you who
knows where your commander is going to
be
you're freaking flying in the dark or
you're jumping out of an airplane how
what's your grouping how many people are
you going to be close to
so that not everyone
i mean they have almost no
communications
so what we have to do is we have to make
sure
that everyone understands the
commander's intent everyone has to have
some kind of objective
so the more we got to this modern
warfare
the more decentralized command was and
the more
importance there was on commander's
intent
then what happens then we start getting
radios
right so now all of a sudden hey leif
you go there i'll call
you i'll let you know what to do when we
get there or if you get into trouble or
if it's not what you expected
give me make calms
so now all of a sudden i'm allowed to d
or i'm not allowed
i naturally ease towards taking the
stress off of the
commander's intent because i figure just
give me a call when you hit the ground
if it's not what we expected
so when you think about if you're gonna
freaking launch gliders and paratroopers
into france for d-day you gotta expect
they're gonna hit the ground they're
gonna have no idea where they are what
to do
they're gonna have no communications
with you they better they let me
rephrase that
they're going to have no communications
with you when they hit the ground
they are probably not even going to have
communications with
more than five or six people when they
initially hit the ground maybe 10.
you know maybe if it's a glider they're
all together
but they're going to be isolated so they
have to
understand the commander's intent
otherwise it just stops right there
but as soon as we get radio
communications
now it's like okay well you know when
you hit the ground
check in for the objectives only you
know if you if you're not sure where you
are
give us a call and we'll so all of a
sudden commander's intent becomes less
important
and then you get to oh less important if
you if you can make radio comes
less important if you can make radio
comps so then you get you fast forward
you know uh to vietnam where maybe now
every
platoon has a radio right every platoon
has a radio so now what we at least can
can control that then you fast forward
to the to the 90s like even when i first
got in the teams
we might not have a radio for each guy
in the platoon there might be like four
guys don't get a radio
hey make sure you stick with one of the
you know because you're doing like a
shipboarding like
hey if you don't got a radio make sure
you stick with somebody that does
but now pretty much we don't need to
even know anything
by the time we get to the teams in the
we've all got radios we've all got
radios
so so now i can control more life tell
me what's going hey
give me a status update so i can tell
you what to do
next and then you go to the 2010s now
all of a sudden i got a blue force
tracker i got a video of what we're
doing and you can see where now we're
becoming
we're going away from decentralized
command and moving
closer and closer to more
micromanagement
because the technology allows me
as the leader to
move those chess pieces as i see fit
and it feels comfortable it feels more
comfortable to do that of course we know
it's wrong
because for me to be like leif give me a
status upright date so i can give you
you know
your next move oh well my status update
oh yeah jocko
we're getting flanked right now what do
you want me to do
oh i want you to oh leif just got shot
why because he didn't react quickly
enough because he's sitting there
waiting to be told what to do
so what we're seeing now is a tendency
to move
more towards centralized command because
we have the technology to
facilitate centralized command
i'm not saying it's right i'm saying
it's bad it's wrong
but it's that's the reason that it's
happening we're starting to see more and
more micromanagement because we have the
technology that facilitates it as you're
saying that i'm thinking about
uh you know i'm thinking about as the
training that you ran
was you know which was the best freaky
training in the world
when you were the officer in charge of
training detachment you know here for
the west coast seal teams
and you know your instructors were were
out there
to teach to teach people how hard it was
going to be particularly in the urban
environment you know
in a combat situation how easily you can
get in blue on blue situation
how easily things to go chaotic how
easily you can't actually make comms on
the radio
um you know or the land warfare
environment exactly the same thing and
distances or ridge lines in the way or
whatever it may be and
because it seems that way in theory you
know it seems that all in theory we just
talked to everybody on the radio and
give me a call
just radio which deer will deconflict oh
great and then when you realize like hey
uh that's not going to work if we can't
make comps and you talk about
shipboarding that's a great example like
hey i'm down in the engine room and
there's a whole bunch of steel between
me and you up on the bridge
i got no comms with you whatsoever and
if you're thinking that like
hey i just made a call on the radio and
everyone heard me
and i tried to do them you taught me
that and it one of the one of the
biggest lessons for me
you know as as we've talked about here
and you know podcasts
you know years back is is is trying to
put out
you know a message over the radio hey
everyone do this do that and you were
like use verbal commands
and that was one of those things like
not everyone is hearing me on the radio
they're in the middle of doing stuff
there's people that are on the third
story and they're talking to a bunch of
walls and they might
they may not even be hearing your
transmission so this illusion that i'm
communicating
you know is is uh is it's a total
illusion because it's not the reality
and and if people don't have commander's
intent they can't execute and there's no
substitute for that at all
and we see that now right in the
business world
as the leader sent out an email or you
know hey i told everybody what to do
they should just read their email like
hey are you guys in the field on their
email
24 7. they're they're in the middle of
doing stuff by the way they got 14
emails
at six o'clock in the morning and you
think that they're gonna take that one
from you and be like oh especially
especially if you're the kind of leader
that sends out hey
just checking in with everyone letting
no one know what's going on like no
no don't send me check-in emails you're
going to email
if i'm emailing you there's a reason for
it you need to open it up and read it
that means i'm not going to email you 12
times a day
i'm not even gonna email you three times
a day when you get an email from me
it's important if you set the precedence
that i'm gonna send you a bunch of stuff
that doesn't matter guess what
same thing with with coming up on the
radio hey i actually need uh
hey anyone's got a another uh uh humvee
we can push back in this area
i i can't really get two more guys i'm
just talking on the radio talking on the
radio talking on the radio
eventually no one's listening to you
anymore we worked with a company
recently where uh they're running the
plant and the plant is
being managed from a couple hundred
miles away we're in like a command
center
uh and they lost power
so they lose power and and all of a
sudden like hey they got no calms
at all everything has to be done on site
you know and if you don't understand
commander's attention if you don't
understand what those procedures are
i mean you've got to have those
contingency plans in place and i think
that was what was so awesome about
about seeing that at uh you know at
trade when you're running things is
you're instilling those lessons of like
okay
this is why i've got to make sure that
my junior leaders my squad leaders
you know can step up and make calls uh
because if
regardless of the technology that we
have we're gonna fail
if they can't yeah there would always be
the the troop coming through and they'd
say well
i do well how are you coordinating that
they're like oh we're just gonna get on
the radio and when it's go time and i'd
be like
what if you don't get comms and they
would kind of look at me puzzled and it
get if you
if you make your plan this is the this
should be the fifth law of combat
the fifth law of combat is if you make
your plan and it's based on
making commun radio communications with
some other element
and your plan relies on that it will not
work
it will not work it is going to fail
you've got to have
you know secondary tertiary forms of
communication that
overcome the radio as you're saying i'm
thinking about the image of you standing
on top of a humvee
at uh entry control point three
on the far side of the canal when we had
all this danger of snipers around there
and and uh
we knew that this was there was sniper
activity like no one actually peeked
their head above the big
hesco barriers jack was standing on top
of the humvees with his
tape antenna you know extended to like
six or eight feet above his head
to make comms with me you know as as i
was we were forward and uh
in an overwatch position and and even
then it was it was it was a recognition
of like hey we
we're it's gonna be really hard to talk
on the radio
um you know and and you you didn't you
put yourself at risk to do that but
if i didn't have commander's attention i
mean i there's no way i could i could
rely on that to
have you make the calls for me you know
from a distant position uh
i wanted to say one thing about this and
uh you talked about you know
the power of the flag and we talked
about in that previous you know the
germans that run up the flag and the
french were
demoralized nothing more demoralizing
than uh a giant burning tank hole
you know the hulk of that tank just just
burning there that
all the all the others can see and uh
that uh that was obviously incredibly
demoralizing in this particular
situation
um and i think when you oh oh i see what
you're saying you're talking about this
particular
where he hit this tank with the with the
p.i yeah he hit the tank with a rocket
all of a sudden you know
the tank explosion it's a big fireball
and clearly that was a
massively demoralizing thing for the
german forces there which which turned
it around for
the brits but i think uh yeah running up
flags is great
um blowing up tanks and
having a burning uh vehicle and for all
to see
like ooh i don't want that happen to me
yeah the reason it took me a second
there is because
the times that american tanks got blown
up in ramadi and it would take
you know 24 hours to get a 88 down there
to
drag them out and that was freaking
demoralizing too you know and
we we talked about the vehicle graveyard
but just knowing that
they're gonna get some the enemy's gonna
get theirs and it's
freaking horrible it was incredibly
demoralized right to drive down you know
route michigan and see some burned out
hulk of a vehicle on the side of the
road but the good news was on our side
it was also very demoralizing you know
when
the bad guys could observe their their
buddies laying out in the street
after some seal snipers put them in the
dirt
yeah and uh that was pretty demoralizing
as well for them
which we took some pride in chuck
next sergeant stephen gregg
us army italy 1944. in august of 1944
the allied offensive
in italy was stalemated an amphibious
landing at anzio was executed in an
attempt to outflank the german defenses
and capture rome
the landing units became stalled on the
beachhead allow
allowing the germans to reinforce their
defenses
the day after the landing l company of
the 143rd
infantry was moving north towards rome
the germans were waiting in ambush
and the company was quickly pinned down
by enemy fire realizing that the fire
was too heavy for the medics to tend to
the wounded
sergeant greg a mortar men picked up a
30 caliber light machine gun and
advanced on the enemy position
his his measured accurate bursts
suppressed the enemy long enough for the
casualties to be evacuated
unfortunately sergeant greg ran out of
ammunition it was captured
while sergeant greg's captors took cover
from incoming art
american artillery sergeant greg grabbed
the machine pistol
and fought his way back to friendly
lines
i sometimes i'd pause because i'm
thinking about these things in a little
bit deeper level
like picking up a 30 caliber light
machine gun which it says light machine
gun a 30 caliber machine
light and just advancing on the enemy
position
that's just awesome and then you picture
this guy
we start getting hit with artillery
and all the captors hide
and he's like oh check you little babies
watch this grabs a machine pistol fights
his way back the front lines
the next day the germans
counter-attacked l company
sorry the next day the germans counter
attacked el company was ordered to hold
the line on a hill captured the day
before acting as a forward observer
observer
sergeant greg directed over 600 rounds
onto the enemy until he lost
communications with the mortar section
knowing how important the mortar fire
was to the defense sergeant greg took
the initiative to find out what had
happened to the phone line
upon nearing the mortar section another
soldier yelled that the germans had
seized the mortar position and were
dropping rounds on the americans
sergeant gregg assaulted the germans
taking two prisoners
he quickly put the mortars back into the
fight by gathering up a handful
of american troops and teaching them how
to fire mortars
ojt l company
held the line sergeant greg's bravery
initiative and situational awareness
contributed to his unit's
successful defense the defeat of the
german counter-attack led to the allied
breakout from the beachhead and the
eventual capture
of rome that's just a solo
op right there that's crazy this solo
operation
i'm gonna go check check out i'm gonna
go find out what's going on with this
phone wire
oh wait a second there's some germans
with our mortars cool i'm
what do i do oh i attacked them okay
give me a 30
30 cal machine gun let's get some
sergeant gregg displayed keen station
lessons sergeant
greg displayed keen situational
awareness during combat at ancient while
acting as a forward observer
sergeant greg realized the importance of
his unit's role in the company defense
and did everything in his power to keep
the mortise firing so
this says he realized the importance
role like he realized what's going on
there was no one told him
we better get those mortars up he
realized it and made something happen
when
ambushed sergeant greg displayed the
bravery and decisiveness to take action
his individual attack on the germans
lifted the pressure
on his unit and allowed the wounded to
be evacuated sergeant greg's leadership
abilities and strength of character
allowed him to take a handful of
americans not under his command
and train them while under enemy fire
sergeant greg's improvised section
maintained the supporting fires which
were so critical to the company's
defense
action or is this the common theme
action look they talk about initiative
that's good they talk about
understanding the
commander's intent but actually taking
action
is is what we need to do
uh in the book called extreme ownership
when we talked about prioritizing
execute one of the things that
that i had told stoner was you know
wrote it on his thing relax look around
and make a call
and what's interesting about that is
when i wrote that there's a part missing
there's a part missing to that so
when you get into a situation where
there's a lot of mayhem going on
what you need to do is relax you know
take a breath
look around actually observe what's
happening and then make a call
right make a call now there's a part
that's when you line that up with the
ooda loop
it almost lines up perfectly
because uh observe orient decide and act
we got relax which is like all right
look around which is definitely observe
and then make a call is decide
the thing that i didn't say to seth
was was act and i would have said
execute i would have used the word
execute
i didn't put that on the windshield for
him the reason that i didn't put that on
the windshield for him
is because
when you tell a sealed platoon to do
something
nine times out of ten it's going to get
executed when someone says
online the word gets passed they get
online when someone says
peel right they get online they appeal
right when someone says strong right
strong left when somebody makes a call
it gets executed
and his platoon was executing stuff
it was him that needed to make a call so
that's that's the piece that i didn't
tell
seth because i didn't need to because it
wasn't him that was he was going to make
the call
his platoon was going to execute and and
believe me they did
you know when he would make a call or
when someone would make a call they'd
execute that's pretty
normal it's very normal for a sealed
platoon it's very seldom that a seal
platoon when they get
when they get told to execute something
that they don't do it if you make a call
jp durnell is executed
yeah you picture you've got 16 jp denils
or even if you got five jp danelles and
some other guys
shit's gonna happen it's gonna happen
so when i wrote that for seth it was
about him
and the execute part i didn't have to
say anything because i knew if he made a
call
it was gonna happen that's a
that's a big assumption for
a lot of for it's a big assumption for
us as individuals and it's a big
assumption
in a normal team right look i knew
delta platoon at that time and like i
said most steel platoons
quite frankly they will execute as we
just said but that's not always common
and it's something that
you should we should actually add if
you're going to say hey if when there's
things happening relax look around and
make a call
the next thing should be execute because
there's people that make calls there's
people that make calls and businesses
there's people that make calls in
dynamic situations they make a call but
if you haven't
trained and been been
for lack of a better word programmed
that when you hear a call you're going
to execute
there's often times when the execution
doesn't happen
the reason i'm bringing this up is
because i was thinking about this
because
every one of these things the common
thing is that somebody's taking action
it's not someone's making a decision
they're making a decision too but they
have to act and even when dave talks
about the ooda loop
you know he he says that the most
important part of the ooda loop is
action it's action you got it you got to
take action if you don't take action
look you can
observe orient decide all day long if
you don't act
it doesn't matter and same thing with
relax look around and make a call
hey you can relax and orient yourself
and observe what's happening and make a
call but if nobody executes that call
you're dead in the water so these things
are all about
actually taking action
it's a it's a great observation because
that's that's the breakdown for a lot of
leaders and we see that all the time you
know
with a decision gets made and we're
working with a company and you know
they've got a problem performer and
they've done everything they can to
train and mentor them and they
okay we're gonna have to actually make
this the decision to to let them go
and then you come back and talk to them
six weeks later and the decision got
made
but they never executed and the
performer's still there and then
it takes six months or nine months to
get that done and
it's so much harder to do then uh and
all the damage has been done
and and i think that's a great
observation to me because it's a you
know you can make a decision but if
you're not actually executing
it and it doesn't it it gives you uh
you're setting yourself back you're
losing the initiative
uh you're wasting you know momentum
you're giving your competition
uh a leg up and you know to your point
earlier like nine times out of ten
action is the best thing yeah take
action take an interview step the
direction you need to know
you need to go uh and it just gives you
all the advantage in the world
yeah and occasionally you could get a
platoon where
they're not you know they don't have
that they don't have that
attitude where they're like okay the
calls got made and we're gonna go make
this happen
occasionally you would get a platoon
like that and then then it would be
hey would you hear that call you gotta
you gotta go get on that you gotta make
that happen you gotta you gotta execute
like i said delta platoon didn't need
that they just needed seth to
freaking relax look around and make a
call once the call was getting made dude
they had experienced guys in there and
like you said you got some
you got some jp dentals and some other
freaking guys that are gonna make things
happen in there
it's no factor
action
next one corporal david w lamb us army
korea 1951.
in october 1951 g company 23rd infantry
regiment was battling for hill
520 of heartbreak ridge the company had
been withered by
repeated fights with the north korean
forces corporal lam was acting platoon
commander
of the third platoon of a unit of about
20 soldiers
so we got the the freaking e4 out there
acting as a platoon commander
following heavy bombardment and
supporting fires corporal lamb's platoon
made a direct assault on hill 520.
upon nearing the enemy lam's platoon was
halted by enemy fire and began taking
casualties
lamb called back for reinforcements
lieutenant gayno
gathered his first platoon and moved
towards lamb's position
gano's platoon began to take casualties
and halted when the young lieutenant was
killed
private high stepped into the role of
platoon commander and rallied his
platoon
while under fire corporal lamb directed
the use of supporting fires and planned
a new route for the enemy attack for the
company attack
after a bitter fight the two platoons
breached the enemy defenses
during the assault on the position
corporal lamb was wounded private high
was now the main effort of the attack he
directed the remaining soldiers
in taking out the bunkers in the enemy
defenses
using grenades and flamethrowers
three hours after the attack had set off
the ending position was secured corporal
lamb's leadership had pulled his platoon
and the remainder of g company forward
threw the withering fire into the
enemy's position
the attack pushed the enemy off hill 520
an important an important step in
removing
resistance from heartbreak ridge
you know what's interesting i'll a lot
of times tell leaders you know
you should have if you got
seven or eight direct reports you should
have two or three of those direct
reports that are ready to step
up and and take your job
and and here you got a private you know
this guy is this guy is a freaking
private
and he takes charge and makes things
happen that's next level right
hey it should be imagine me saying hey
look you got your direct reports and of
all your direct reports
your eight direct reports you should
have two people that are ready to take
your job and by the way
in their direct reports there should be
five people that are ready to take your
job
that's impressive
and if you if you made that your goal
that the people
not just your subordinates their
subordinates there was people that were
there there were two levels below you in
the chain of command are going to step
up and take your job if it need be
imagine how effective and efficient
those
individuals would be freaking awesome
like you talk about all the time like
every leader should be trying to work
themselves out of a job and i think it's
so hard to do that because
our egos get involved you're like why i
want to be the one that makes
calls and you know but you you insisted
on that i know you'd learned that from
uh from delta charlie in in your time in
in the the seal teams and
putting like ryan ryan jobs our our most
junior ranking guy
as a an e3 and we put him in charge of
running an entire assault like planning
and executing that assault and
you know he did good it was it was it
made him
so much of a greater contributor because
he understood
what you know the the he understood the
challenges of leadership he understood
how he could best support
you know the overall team and then what
kind of information we needed to make
decisions
and i would have never done that without
your encouragement and in fact i think i
pushed back on a little bit
you and you're like hey why don't you
let who's your most junior
why don't you let why don't you let
vehicles run this and i was like
are you sure about that are you like
he's a he's brand new and and you're
like yeah just let him run it
let's see what he does he'll do fine yep
and that's the that's that's the crazy
thing right there right it's like
he'll do fine and he'll be fine yeah
he's totally fine
he'll be he'll do fine he'll do fine
it's like even when we run ftx it's like
the ftx training program for
civilians what
i i don't know how we had this talk
or when it was but the overall the
overall
um the overall meaning of the talk was
was like they'll be fine like the these
civilians that got
45 minutes of training of how to assault
the building
they're actually going to do fine it
won't be that big of a deal look
is a sealed platoon better trained yes
but i'm saying the general idea of what
they're doing is going to be
it's going to be fine it's going to be
enough to work with and and so
someone like bagels who who's like in
the platoon and going through the work
up and
understands things it's like he he'll
watch this he'll do it
he'll do it fine and you know he'll make
the same he'll make
you just did it leif babin the platoon
commander from the naval academy you
know
you just did it and you made four
mistakes
and biggles is about to do it and he's
gonna make five
it's not like leif just did it and he
made one mistake and biggle's gonna do
it he's gonna make 80.
no it's like it's like i made seven
mistakes and he made three that's yeah
yeah yeah
it's like that crazy and and the
the thing that you mentioned about how
much more it opens up
somebody's brain when they get to see
like all that when you're in charge of
all this exactly you called it this is
what delta charlie did dust
hey you're in charge of this you're
running this and all of a sudden instead
of me looking at this little tiny sliver
of the plan
and the sliver of the execution i'm
looking at this whole big thing and so i
see
so much more see how things are
interconnected that was such a powerful
am i going to use this word yes i am
life changing
life changing for me to have
the vision and to have my boss say
you're gonna run this
and and get to run it and see all these
things that i'd never seen before
and be like and then the next mission by
the way i'm back to just being a radio
man
but i can see all the connections i know
the importance of the job i know that i
my i know that this would help my boss i
know that this would help the other the
other
squad leader i know that i should talk
to this guy about
it just makes you infinitely better
that was a really powerful lesson that
that that i learned from you
and and saw the impact and i think that
if leaders can just simply put their ego
in check
and realize just to your point that you
had with those seal platoon commanders
and task indemners think if you had
think if you had 16 or 40 of those guys
out there
who can see that vision who are thinking
about not just their tasks but every
how can they can help the overall
mission and the intent the purpose that
you're out here you know trying to
accomplish
it's just absolutely life-changing and
game changing and that
that team is just they just dominate
there's no there's no stopping that dude
they just crush everything
some lessons corporal lamb
displayed tremendous leadership
abilities his fellow soldiers benefited
from his competence
when he assumed command of the platoon
and led a company-sized attack
when the time came for him to command at
a higher level he was able to shoulder
the responsibility
tactically proficient corporal lam had
learned the necessary skills for
commanding a platoon in combat
check he was able to coordinate
supporting fires with his company
commander
direct actions direct the actions of
other platoons and inspire the men
under his command by his personal
leadership his knowledge and ability met
with the success on the battlefield
by the way i got a i got a text from uh
tilt the other day
and it was after he listened to a
podcast with um with
dave burke good deal dude yes good deal
dave
a good deal dave was telling uh you know
talking about calling for bombs calling
fire calling for fire
in ramadi and i don't know the number of
times that
that dave was on the ground to drop
bombs but you know it was
a lot yeah it was a lot
and then tilt listened to it until it
was like
hey really like listening to your your
podcast with
burke uh let him know that i got to call
some fire too
only i was an e4 when i did it and
and and it is you could not
you could not compare the amount of
times that dave
burke dropped bombs in his
entire career including training
you could not compare that amount with
the amount that tilt dropped
on one operation one operation
where he's sitting at night for 12 hours
with continual close air support
tilt will make you feel like a
baby yeah i don't think you're uh i
don't think you're measuring up to uh
i don't think you're measuring up to
that in any way before but look that's
you know we talk about humility and i
think that's any time i think i've done
something or we saw some combat you know
and you start reading
books i mean every single one of these
of these uh
illustrations here i mean it just just
blows away
anything that i saw or did it's
incredible
i will say this though i talked to i i
did i talked to uh
you know a couple of vietnam seals
they're outstanding you know folks that
had some awesome experience
and uh had served as seal machine
gunners in vietnam and they talked about
being in some gun fights and
i mean these guys i mean amazing you
know incredible people
who had awesome experiences our
forefathers that created this legacy you
know for us in the seal teams and
we were talking about machine seal
machine gunners you know and how man it
was really cool to see our bellefield
machinery
kept us alive and how awesome they were
and and we were talking about like how
often
you know i so i asked i asked one of
them a good friend of mine
how many times you have to reload your
machine gun he's like oh man maybe
a couple times i was like well how many
i mean you must have shot your whole
load out a few times you know
a bunch of times he was like no i don't
think i ever shot my whole load up and i
was thinking like
dude our seal machine gonna shot the
their entire
600 round loadout and then maybe four or
500 more rounds that everybody else was
carrying like
all the time on so many of those
operations yeah
the i i had the same conversation with
um
with well i had this exact same
conversation with
one you know badass forefather
vietnam seal who was a machine gunner in
nam
and he said the same thing you know he
was like um he i think he said he's like
yeah we got in six firefights
but that's what i also learned is that
much like
current seal deployments you could have
one seal deployment
in vietnam where you go to a certain ao
and the enemies act in a certain way
and it's freaking like daily
craziness and they were doing what they
oh yeah they do since they would do
squad operations so they go every other
night your squad my squad your squad my
squad
and they would do operations all the
time so is also
um you know based on the particular ao
that you know that you were in i mean
even when we were when we were in ramadi
the guys that were over in
another city you know whatever not not
that far away
some of those guys didn't didn't i don't
know if they got in firefights so or
maybe they got you know two or three so
it's one of those things where i hate to
use this word but you gotta get
lucky with your ao you know and then of
course
you gotta make your own luck
next up sergeant stephen bouchard
u.s marine corps vietnam 1967. in july
of 1967
first battalion 9th marines took part in
operation buffalo designed to defend the
border between north and south vietnam
known as the
demilitarized zone during this operation
the battalion was ambushed by an entire
north vietnamese army
regiment and took very heavy casualties
the first and second battalions third
marines were sent to rescue one nine and
stabilize the area
sergeant bouchard served as the right
guide for 2nd platoon a company
1-3 the platoon's mission was to clear
the area where 1-9 had left their dead
as a company moved out of its positions
second platoon came under heavy
shell fire the platoon commander was
wounded and had to be medevaced
the platoon sergeant took command the
nva began
firing from bunkers in the far tree line
the platoon sergeant froze with fear
leaving the platoon
without leadership sergeant bouchard
unhesitatingly
took command of the platoon and played
an important role in the company's
subsequent actions
sergeant bruchard's strong leadership
pulled the platoon through the horrible
task of retrieving the corpses
of one nine while under enemy fire while
manning a defensive position a breach in
the battalion line was created between
bouchard's platoon
and the adjacent b company bouchard's
platoon
counter-attacked into the breach and
sealed off the nva
who had infiltrated the perimeter his
unit then made contact with approaching
forces
wearing marine gear sergeant bouchard
ordered his marines to hold their fire
until the figures had come
into within hand grenade range at that
time bouchard decided to open fire on
the approaching soldiers
who were nva wearing stolen gear from
the dead
of the one-nine bouchard's
tactical actions broke the enemy attack
and the marines
went on the offensive
sergeant bouchard remained in command of
second platoon until the unit
was ordered to pull out a13 was the last
unit to leave the battlefield before
b-52 strikes leveled the area
sergeant bouchard was both willing and
able to take responsibility of
leading the platoon his tactical skills
allowed the platoon to play a major role
in the company's combat operation
sergeant bouchard was able to take
charge by being decisive
we recorded a whole thing yesterday on
for ef online
on being decisive the squad leaders did
not respond to the platoon sergeant who
was too fearful
to lead sergeant bouchard took decisive
action and was not afraid to make tough
decisions and carry out difficult tasks
and once again what did he do he took
action
taking action his decision to open fire
on the individuals in marine uniforms
required decisiveness and acceptance of
responsibility
sergeant bouchard led his platoon by
example many marines were devastated by
the sight of the marine dead
left behind by one nine sergeant
bouchard's capable and firm leadership
held
second platoon together and that right
there
i mean is just devastating you know you
know we talked about
the how how much it hurt to see
an american tank burning in in the
streets in ramadi
i mean can you imagine your platoon is
now out there just
recovering body after body after body
of your fellow marines i mean it's a
it's a nightmare
and and obviously they didn't go into it
too much
and i i'll have to do some research and
if i can find any more information about
this but
you know they clearly mention it here
many marines were devastated by the
sight of the marine dead left behind
by one nine
realizing that his unit had to be at the
right place at the right time in order
to make a difference sergeant bouchard
led a counter-attack to plug the gap in
the lines between a
and b companies this platoon level
tactical action secured the company
flank
and prevented the battalion from being
split and overrun
and there's a quote here from the german
army that says it's better to have a
good sergeant in command
than a bad officer we'll take that one
that's that's a great quote right there
corporal lester a tully u.s marine corps
vietnam
1968. the 1968 ted offensive took
american forces in vietnam by surprise
way city the ancient imperial capital of
vietnam was quickly overrun by the north
vietnamese army
the nva given the mission of relieving
the first arvin division command post g
company
2nd battalion 5th marines advanced on
foot through the city
the first arvin division cp was located
at the northern corner of the citadel
a historic fortress g company's route of
advance would take them right through
the citadel
the company advanced along highway one
with second platoon in the lead
until it became necessary to cross a
bridge over the perfume river
just as the lead squad crested the
center of the span
an nva machine gun and placed in a
fortified bunker opened fire
the company was pinned on the bridge and
the lead squad took
multiple casualties
an m60 was set up to counter the nva
position but the team leader was killed
moments later
as sparks flew from enemy rounds hitting
the bridge structure
corporal tully decided to take matters
into his own hands
corporal tully was second squad leader
of second platoon
on the bridge his squad was located
directly behind the lead squad
assessing the situation corporal tully
decided upon a course of action that
would allow his company to advance
realizing that his squad was protected
from fire
and was the nearest to the enemy
corporal tully
charged up a walkway and threw a grenade
into the enemy position killing
five nva and silencing the position the
company
followed corporal tully's squad crossed
the bridge and advanced upon the citadel
as the company neared the citadel it
meant heavy resistance from northern
vietnamese army regulars while forced to
withdraw
gulf 2 fied gulf 2-5 clarified the
situation around the citadel
american commanders had gained a much
needed clearer picture of how strong the
enemy was in way city
now the american commanders could
concentrate on what to do
rather than wondering what was going on
that's a you know we used to set up the
the old barricaded shooter down a
hallway
this is just an awful one a barricaded
shooter down the bridge
and what are you gonna do you got downed
men on that bridge because you think oh
well i'll just jump off the ridge and
we'll be okay what about your wounded
friends up there
so you can't just abandon it it's a
nightmare
what's up with the what's up with a
grenade killing five
nva that's a that must have been a
that's a tight shot they must have been
closely grouped i mean
like way tightly grouped that's a well
well thrown girl that's a well-thrown
grenade
i always loved that that that you know
the uh i guess
yeah the the american grenades being
like baseballs
baseball side and the germans they
couldn't they couldn't hang
because they play soccer and so they you
know what a potato masher grenade is
echo charles
no you're you ever seen a a grenade with
like a long
stick on one end of it yeah like on red
don yeah so that's called a potato
masher because it looks like something
potatoes but the reason that it was
created was
you can use it like with leverage to
throw further yeah yeah
because you can't kick a grenade like
it's a soccer ball
so they couldn't throw like america you
take an american kid man come on
he's gonna take that little baseball
sized grenade and huck that thing
strike he's gonna put it into a machine
gun pick go five people
accuracy freaking awesome yeah if you
remember from from easy company
that with with the the two 506 the
banner banner brothers if you've seen
the the uh the television show read the
book
but uh remember buck compton was the
all-american
uh catcher for the ucla's baseball team
and he was like he was apparently direct
line drive
hitting german soldiers with with
hangman that's so freaking
epic that's so epic i was uh
when i was going through stt like the
what became sqt so you know the
you get done with basic skill training
and you show up at a team and then they
put you through training and that we
we went through a grenade course which
was just run by team guys
but we were throwing pineapple grenades
straight up pineapple grenades the
crates were marked 1947. what's the
pineapple grenade
that your dish looking grenade it sort
of looks like a pineapple
it's got the little like spikes spikes
on it yeah it's like
like a like a quad pattern oh yeah it's
just like a
stereotypical grenade oh yeah like okay
what you
look like if someone's gonna get a
tattoo of a grenade right right that's
what they get
okay so the and then what then the kind
of modern grenades that's just the
rounds
just yeah it just looks round but that
that those pineapple grenades so we go
up there
and this is just dumb team guy stuff
so we start throwing these grenades and
like a bunch of them are not working
because they're
whatever at that time like 50 years old
or something crazy like that
so we're hucking these grenades and uh
the chief that was running the training
who it was a freaking like badass team
guy matter of fact tony mentioned him
because
he he uh died but his name is tim
ferrell
and so we're throwing these grenades and
when they would so if if you threw a
grenade and it didn't go off
the protocol was shut down the range
call eod
eod can come out there whatever in five
hours
and you're gonna sit there for five
hours waiting for them to show up so
tim ferrell didn't want us to miss
training so he's going out on the range
he'd like be like he'd give it like
whatever a few minutes
and then he'd take another grenade
another freaking
old rusty pineapple grade he would go up
pull the pin
set it down next to the one that was the
dud after he went out there looking for
it that's balls
set it down and then run back and jump
into the pit
and dude i'm a new guy i'm like damn
dude this dude's a badass like this
guy's
crazy but that's you know that's how if
you're out there running hand grenade
ranges do not
do not do that do not do that do not do
that
not advisable like i said dumb team guy
stuff
freaking don't real dumb those those
pineapple grenades so that you know the
m67 which is the mod around grenades we
use it that
it the frag pattern is is so much the
frag is tiny it breaks up into those
little little small pieces where the
pineapple guys got those big old chunks
and that's what the that's what
the the uh insurgents had in ramadi yeah
yeah
oh yeah they have those uh they have
those russian ones that are more
cylindrical yeah they're cylindrical
and they still have the grid pattern on
them yeah we recovered a bunch of those
out of that one moss that we cleared
with iraqi soldiers
imagine that sweet you guys stash all
their weapons there so you don't use the
pineapple grenades
at all no more long-term no dang that's
kind of the iconic
look yeah that's what i'm saying if
you're gonna get a tattoo of a grenade
you're gonna get that one
most like i've never seen anyone with an
m67 grenade tattoo have you
i haven't yeah because it it's kind of
round right yeah
it doesn't quite have the it's kind of
boring yeah
i remember some of those pineapple the
russian pineapple graves were those
things were heavy they had a lot more
a lot more weight a little more oomph to
them for sure it seemed like most
well like you said the frag was heavier
you know like just the just the metal
was heavy
i don't know what the explosive weight
was off the top of my head
they're definitely bigger they make a
big boom i can tell you that
so there's different sizes of grenades
or no
yes there are like so well you you
mentioned that the grenade killed
however many guys in one shot that was
more a statement of like
that must have been a hell of a shot and
the guys must have been close together
because a grenade is a very small
explosive i mean it's a yeah it's a
small
five five meter kill right yeah yeah
yeah so it's yeah if they're all
cruising together boom
here's a note for echo charles though uh
with the movie master
yes sir the so the the the five meter
kill radius for m67 our hand grenade
frag grenade is the same it's the same
kill radius for a golden egg which is a
40 millimeter grenade that you shoot out
of your
your m203 grenade launcher or the old
school m79s that we we carried
and uh unlike what you might see in the
movie commando
when when you when you shoot a 40 mm
grenade
the building doesn't blow up and we had
several times where
it just it fragged people and they run
off and so yeah
that's a common disappointing no there's
a common misconception that actually is
true
and commando is actually factually the
proof that it
doesn't do that well all i gotta say is
i tried that many times and as an
officer you know my my job is to stand
back and
and high point my weapon and be detached
but that also means that if i'm in the
back i can shoot some 40 millimeter
grenades and we
we've shot quite a few of those things
which was awesome i remember you
uh often coming back with uh empty
bandoliers
[Music]
so wait on predator no no no
they started totally did start it um
remember
the scene on predator jesse ventura
blaine aka blaine says i don't i don't
have time to bleed right remember that
part
yeah it's like hey you believe and then
the guy pancho said okay do you have
time to duck
exactly he came out shot is that the 40
millimeter that's a forty nine
yeah he had an m203 so he's launching
that into the
unlike like look it would definitely
keep guys heads down and if and we did
have
we had a couple guys that just scored
some direct hits with a 40 millimeter
grenade which is
if you take one of those in the chest
it's game over for you uh
that was pretty epic but uh but there
there is uh
what what doesn't happen is like you saw
on predator where you launch a 40
milligram
a 40 40 mic mic into a bunker
and like a giant explosion happens and
six guys go flying 10 feet in the air in
all directions
that doesn't happen that was pretty
disappointing did you see my instagram
post where i said hey people are parking
in front of my driveway
and then i shoot the cars yes is that a
40 millimeter
i mean i guess i thought you had a
rocket wasn't that a rocket right now it
was like one
you know the big i think like six of
them fit in there
oh you know what you did have you had
the street sweeper there's a street
sweeper 40 millimeter name which the
marines had yeah
the eight marines had some and they're
heavy but it's pretty awesome it's just
it's a cylinder and so yeah you can just
launch a whole bunch of
yeah it's basically like a gigantic
revolver with 40 millimeter
that wasn't real it was real but i don't
look at the tag
what do you call the instructions or
whatever the name i don't know i i did
shoot some vehicles with 40
mic it does create quite an explosion
and if you can ignite the gas you know
then
then it will catch on fire there wasn't
a gigantic explosion that happened
though that was a little disappointing
yeah you got to go in good deal dave for
the bombs
yeah there's just not that much
explosive inside i mean you don't
like how big a m80 is yeah i mean
think of how big an m80 is well then
think of how big a grade is i mean i can
just kind of multiply that and
you're going to get something similar so
do you remember
that they they gave us the thermal
thermobaric 40 mic mics i do remember
that which which
create a much larger explosion and
supposed to kill people with the
overpressure and they
they gave us a bunch of like several
cases of them and that was supposed to
last the entire deployment and
we shot every single one of them uh on
one operation within about a one hour
period
which was awesome that was awesome but
what was also
additionally awesome was i got an email
follow-up
and the they said uh they said something
like
hey we're wondering if you've had a
chance to utilize because they were they
were tested they were testing them
uh we were wondering if they've had a
chance to if you've had a chance to use
any of these thermobaric grenade
40 millimeter grenades and have you had
a chance to fire any of them yet
and i was like hey i was like hey leif
hey i was like have you you shot some of
those how are you guys i shot all of
them
i go how were they like they were
awesome and i just wrote back
uh work good send more
i think i think i asked for more of them
the only thing that was different is
that they
they're much heavier because they're a
lot larger and the explosion is much
much more powerful so a little closer to
what you might expect
gotcha but you you got to account for
that in the trajectory
because uh you didn't open it yet where
you're aiming it is
falling like you know 50 meters short
yeah that's kind of hard to do
i mean can't mark lee just roll out and
dope in your 40 minute mic
that's crazy um all right the lessons
from that one
corporal tully knew the mission
of the company was to relieve the first
arvin division headquarters
when the company was halted by fire he
took decisive action in support of the
commander's intent to free up
the movement of the company so the
mission can be continued
corporal coley acted corporal tully
acted on his own
initiative being the second
in the company formation he was in the
best
position to evaluate the situation and
take
advantage of the opportunity developed
by the point squad
so what we have here again we've got
somebody
that's in a position they're not the
leader
this isn't the gunnery sergeant this
isn't the platoon commander this isn't
the company commander
this is the squad leader who takes
action
and makes a difference and look we
we saw this kind of thing all the time
and we were lucky enough to work
alongside the army work alongside the
marine corps
and see you know not just from our own
platoons not just from charlie and delta
platoon see
our young e5s and step up and make
things happen
we got to see things like this we get to
see things like this all the time
all the time you gotta
you gotta think about how young these
guys inexperienced these squad leaders
are as well too and i was
you know as we're reading hearing those
stories i'm thinking about a
a young squad leader that we worked with
from 3 8 marines
lima company named joe thomsey corporal
joe thompson
and we did probably a dozen operations
with corporal thomsey and his his squad
uh and we learned a lot from those guys
i mean they had been in ramadi for
uh several months prior to us and it
fought through
some of the most difficult and dangerous
neighborhoods and uh
he was he was 21 years old uh
so here's here he is in charge of a
squad of marines
leading those marines a beloved squad
leader
stepping up and making calls supporting
the chain of command
um you know and just just executing and
getting things done
and uh i had so much respect and you
know to be able to work with with a
marine like that and
and uh tragically uh corporal thompson
was killed on august 2nd 2006 the same
day that we lost
markley same day ryan joe was shot
and blinded and uh we
we lined up next to those marines from
38 lima company
and we put both uh joe thomsey and mark
lee
on that angel flight at the same time
and uh i remember the silence of
of of all the marines next to us as as
our seals from charlotte between
carrying those
our brothers and and bodybacked and put
them on that angel flight as
they took off and just the the glow of
that uh
of that helicopter going going uh going
around
uh as they took off to fly those guys
home and uh
what a loss i mean just seeing how
crushed those marines were
losing their their brother and this
beloved squad leader and and i was just
thinking about us as we're hearing
those stories it's hard to to imagine
that these guys
how young they were you know a guy like
corporal thompson 21 years
old and with all that uh you know with
just limited life experience and yet in
this massive position
of responsibility uh that are playing
such key roles in in whether or not
their team succeeds or fails
and uh just my hats off to all the squad
leaders out there and uh
what an honor to work with a guy like
that um and and to reflect on on the
impact that he had on all the marines
that he
he led
yeah that was um
i'm thinking that's probably a pretty
good place to uh stop for today
we got some more we got some more things
to cover
and
it's important to remember that these
guys
you know the guys that we're talking
about in this book when you're talking
about corporal thomsey when you're
talking about mark
you know we talk about how they make a
difference on the battlefield and make a
strategic impact but
their actions and the way they lived and
the example that they sent
definitely have made a difference
in the way that i think in the way that
you think
and the impact that they had not just on
the battlefield but
to see an example to be examples
of what a leader is
and more important what a
person can be
and like i said we'll
we'll pick this up on the on the next
one
but from from these stories that we
heard already
you know i kept referring back to taking
action
and and these
these squad leaders they take action
and they and they make a difference
and and that applies to us as
individuals
our actions make a difference our
actions that we take as people
make a difference not just on the
battlefield
not just in business
[Music]
but in life
so step up take action and make
a difference
all right echo charles it's been a while
but i need some help over here
yes sir why don't you talk for a little
bit all right well
i didn't talk about taking action which
i agree
with obviously um uh well we're gonna
start small how about that
as far as taking action goes so the best
action that we can take
to improve is to improve our physical
health
starts there this is this is essentially
the foundation for
pretty much all other action when you
think about it
okay i was feeling like obviously i was
getting a little bit emotional there
i'm done now you can stop talking
okay we're trying to cool down i think
i'm cool we're good good
what i was gonna say is we gotta start
small okay we're not all
we're not all dressing up like rebels
you know with our friends going in and
shooting the rebel league we're not all
doing that
okay jack that was epic though most of
us
are just kind of you know just going day
to day with her you know
with our lives and tactically and
strategically trying to do the right
thing
right starting small best way to take
action
or the best thing to do is to maintain
or improve our physical health
let's just say it's a great place it's a
definitely a great place to start yes
sir we like it
yes sir can't argue no can't so
improving physical health takes what i
used to call beat downs you got to beat
down your body a little bit
varying levels of beatdowns check we all
worked out today
affirmative some of us planned to work
oh did you not want to go brad not yet
i'm working out later that's what i'm
saying
saying okay he was he said echo was
called
me out earlier for not throwing around
the hundo uh
the the hundo kettlebells you're in
you've been in town for two days
would you be more consistent if you work
with your workouts
if you lived in san diego with me or
like
near me 100
[Music]
sometimes i'm like i wonder if leif
really wants to show up at my house at
five o'clock in the morning
then you get there well how do you feel
when you get there how do you feel once
you're working out
how do you feel once you're done it's
the best the best
it's the best and uh luckily i got i got
an early crossfit class that i usually
hit at 5 30 in the morning
get up at 4 30 stretch out and that's
that's in dripping
dripping springs crossfit second wave
yeah awesome uh
plug coming at you crossfit second wave
awesome gym
how many classes do you have four or
five a day yeah outstanding coaches
great uh great instruction so get after
it
here's a question i have a question for
you okay straight up
you know like okay
okay okay so you know what you just said
like life would you do you think you'd
paraphrasing would you make workouts if
you live in san diego right so the whole
accountability
in early workouts okay when he's going
to get his bro yeah
so you have this thing where and this
kind of me just assuming where
you know when you have a workout partner
you're way less likely to skip workouts
right so for you you might think of
yourself if you're like you know that
doesn't apply to me because alright
script and workouts hell no
kind of thing right but do you believe
that that's a sound theory
i do believe it's a sound theory yeah it
is right yeah it is
yeah so i'm not gonna yeah so when
jocko's like all right i'll see you at
five
that's uh you're gonna be there yeah
you're gonna get something yeah makes
sense
but yeah so through workouts sometimes
you know you gotta beat down your body
so you can recover
you know and through that recover beat
down recovery process we may need a
little support
so we'll start with the joints find it
another foundational
uh concept your joints on your body
track
so we got some supplements we got a lot
of supplements
for pretty much everything so joints is
joint warfare super krill oil
these things maintain your joints so you
don't have to worry about that kind of
stuff so you just worry about the
workout making it to the workout
in life's case and you know and pushing
hard again in life's case i like it so
here's what we're gonna do
for life yeah he's gonna he's gonna get
some good sleep maybe take some of that
hypnosis then he's gonna wake up maybe
have a little discipline
hitter to get to the workout he's gonna
have joint warfare
because his joints are going to be
functioning well with krill oil yes sir
that gets him
gets done guess what he's coming at it
some milk
gonna rebuild with the protein
easy money and then he's got a roll in
here for the podcast cracks open a
discipline go
by the way pretty soon pretty soon
one life babin is going to have his own
signature we're working on that hey um
uh if you want any of this stuff this is
we just started this we're trying to do
a better job
of helping you help yourself
so if any of this stuff that you want
you subscribe to it at origenmain.com if
you subscribe to it
we will ship it to you for free that's
what i said
i said what i said that that
subscription is awesome
too because there's i've over the last
couple years like
the joint warfare and krill oil that
that is the super kill
if i don't take that stuff like i feel
it it's a problem i absolutely feel it
and it there's no question makes a
difference so
that subscription of it just shows up
you're never out it's
it's awesome i love that and also too
like okay so
and consider this would you this is
something you don't really think about
the joint weapon the krill oil
you don't go like through the day
thinking oh can't wait to
take my joint warfare like it's not on
your mind until it's time to take it
so like mo sometimes you can be like hey
i can't kind of can't wait for them
later you know kind of i'm feeling that
right now it's just different it's
insane so when you get into the red zone
as far as
supply of the joint warfare it's like oh
you can kind of understand how you'd get
there
you know but when you have the
subscription man that problem is kind of
avoided it's true though
you know for that kind of stuff so you
can get it at wawa
by the way you can get the drinks at
wawa whole east coast by the way we're
in
we're in whole east coast everyone that
helped us but everyone in florida that
helped us by going in
and clearing shelves it is much
appreciated and you did it
you did it you got wawa full chain whole
east coast no matter where you go you
see a wawa you can go in there and get
yourself some
some discipline go also vitamin shop you
can get it there so
that's cool yes also origin maine.com
origin maine.com you can get american
made
because we're training jiu-jitsu yes you
get american-made ghees rash guards you
can get
that's cool when you're training we
can't wear ghees
in the streets you can not considered
not considered
what appropriate we want to wear jeans
yeah okay cool we got american-made
jeans
american-made jeans american-made boots
t-shirts
hoodies just all kinds of american-made
gear that's true speaking of gear
jocko has a store with gear
dracostore.com this is where you can get
your discipline equals freedom
gear your good gear
your your by to get some t-shirts
let it get some gear yes oh yeah so yeah
a good way to represent
apparel wise your hardcore recondo
oh gear yeah hardcore recondo all day
yes
all available like i said
jacquelinestore.com also
we we have a little uh what's called
what we call the
sh shirt locker
go ahead you don't like how it's no well
i don't know why you made it this weird
thing but we have
the shirt locker yeah see what i'm
saying though like yeah you didn't like
how i said it
the sh you call it locker totally called
it weird
and use is well because it's like the
hurt locker
is what you're saying anyway okay either
way until you get a new shirt every
month
did you put like little tags in those
that says def on it you like that
yeah yeah later on the details with that
one
there's some details in there yes
there's some layers in there as well
anyway some so these are cool design
ideas did you steal that idea from
lululemon
i thought it was lulu melon i don't know
i don't know
no no i didn't though no the answer is
no okay well it looked way cooler
well there you go so you're good either
way yeah look into that a new shirt
every month
cool layers designs represent boom
uh subscribe to this podcast subscribe
to the jocko
unraveling podcast darryl cooper's in
town by the way we're going to be
recording
grounded podcast talking to dean lish
trying to get moving on that warrior kid
podcast i know
i told you when i finished my last book
and got it turned in
we'd we'd get cracking on that so that
was two days ago
another deadline met uh also we have the
underground the jocko underground
jockowunderground.com
if you want to get a little bit more
amplifying information
from the underground you wanna you wanna
see something a little bit what's going
on behind the scenes
you can go to the underground we have uh
a bunch of stuff going on there
we're doing this podcast on there called
the jocko underground
it costs money it costs money because we
don't want to have
we don't want to have sponsors look i
know it's hard enough to listen to us
talk about this stuff right now imagine
if we were talking about something that
we actually didn't like
it would suck really bad yes sir so we
only talk about things that we actually
use that we actually own
that's what we're doing we don't want to
have somebody else hold us
hostage with their many eight dollars
and eighteen cents a month
or if you wanna if you want if you can't
afford that it's okay
email assistance jockowunderground.com
and you'll get taken care of so if
you're gonna if you're if you're feeling
a little bit angry
what are they doing well first of all
this podcast's the same
as long as it can be this way it will be
but if you can't afford it it's okay we
want to help
have you explained the 818 no because
i've had quite a few people ask me that
we haven't yet we're not ready to put
the word out yet no
one person that i can remember guess the
exact one
but that's sort of it layers layers we
got youtube
subscribe to see echo's legit videos
where he has
one of considered one of the be the best
assistant directors
in the world who really kind of guides
the
the whole tone of the videos that's me
yes sir
so you're welcome thank you but you know
what i'm humble that way i just let him
i let him
i let him kind of take the credit for
the videos uh psychological warfare a
bunch of
a bunch of tracks on there
flipsidecampus.com dakota meyer making
stuff
we got books we got a bunch of books we
got final spin
a story a novel a poem i'm not sure
you're gonna have to judge for yourself
it's available for your order right now
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual the cold evaluation of protocols
discipline equals freedom field manual
way of the warrior kid
four field manual way the warrior kid
one two and three mike in the dragons
about faced by colonel david hackworth
and of course of all those books
that i've written the ones that leif
actually thinks are the best are
extreme ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership so you can get those two
which we wrote together echelon front
that is our leadership consultancy where
we solve
problems through leadership go to
echelonfront.com for details on that we
have ef online
which is that's why life's out here we
just recorded four
new sections for ef online
where we go on this particular course we
are going deep into the
into the principles that are in extreme
ownership because you read about them
and you start applying them and you need
some help and you need some adjustment
these are like advanced courses on those
fundamental principles and then we're
very soon we're going to have we're
going to have
those available for all 12 chapters of
extreme ownership we got up we got
an hour-long plus of content in each of
those courses that match each
chapter it's gonna be gonna be awesome
and there's quizzes
and then we do we're doing live stuff
all the time on there so if you've got a
question you can come and ask us that's
efonline.com
by the way if you really want to see
jocko get animated uh if online live
i have fun man i have fun he brings it i
have fun
that's what i do um we have the muster
in 2021
those have kind of changed but go to
extremeownership.com if you want to come
to a live event we've got also the
ftx which is field training that we
talked about a bunch today
how these guys are learning about
leadership you want to go through that
come to our ftx that's what it is and
also we have ef battlefield
where we will take you on a guided tour
to learn
the leadership lessons from the battle
of gettysburg
so check those out ef overwatch where we
are placing
we are placing executives into your
company
that have experience from the military
that know the principles that we talk
about
all the time go to efoverwatch.com and
if you want to help service members
active
and retired their families gold star
families
well a good way to do it is check out
mark lee's mom mama lee she's got a
charity organization and if you want to
donate or you want to get involved go to
america's mightywarriors.org
and if you want to if you just feel the
need to listen to more of my
protracted presumptions or you need to
hear more of
echo's unavailing articulations or lace
tiresome tails
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter
on instagram which echo only refers to
as the gram
and on facebook life is at least babin
on the gram
leaf is at real leif babin because you
don't want to get the other lay back
unreal echo that'd be kind of cool if
you were kind of unreal
echo is adequate charles and i am at
jocko willing and thanks to all the
folks out there
in uniform especially the squad leaders
the squad leaders of the world you make
a difference
in keeping the world safe and to our
police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service
and all first responders thank you for
making a difference
by keeping us safe in our worst times
and to everyone else out there
[Applause]
remember that no matter where you are
no matter what is happening no matter
how outnumbered out gunned out matched
you might be at any particular moment
you make a difference
[Music]
but you only make a difference if you
make
a difference your actions
matter your effort matters your tenacity
matters so don't let off the gas
don't wait for someone else to handle it
for you don't accept your fate
if you don't like it take action
you make the difference and you make the
difference
by taking action and of course by
getting after it
and until next time this is leif and
echo and jocko
out